right good evening everybody welcome to
tonight's plan in East Committee my
name's Andy Crump I will be chairing
tonight's meeting if I could ask
everybody to insure their phones are on
silent or turned off and I'll do the
same as well because obviously we don't
want to be interrupted by the Great
Escape or Andy Pandy or anybody else
whilst people are in full right so but
you never thought you'd come to planning
committee tonight in here Andy Pandy
mentioned but there we are there's
always a first isn't that makes the
changing for it to be because the barn
so right so tell me and sure when people
people are speaking and people who speak
please do not interrupt them it might be
very very tempting but please do not
interrupt them we had enough problems
last week at Planning West so I think
we'll be more refining it on planning
East like to introduce the top table
starting on my right we've got Olivia
Quinn trainer Democratic services
officer and Bynes committee services
make sure - legal services my name is
David Jeffrey I'm the western area team
leader in my role as an impartial
adviser to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arrive doing so
I am bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute planning committee members are
not bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral advice given
Alex cosmetics in your planner
Matthew coy Makana Joe Schobert planner
thank you everybody
go on to item on the agenda Pontius
robsons German we have apologies from
councilor brain for who councillor
kettle is very kindly substituting and
we've got apologies from councillors
Kendall and/or Donnell thank you
discursive interests have we any items
you put your microphone on play I'll
write an email of somebody could you be
a bit more specific with that catch the
pants please you know which from
somebody the name and which application
it refers to at North farm Charrington
is that the one or fouls line okay catch
the st. from the agents concerning North
farm Carrington I could be quite
specific about that I think everyone has
had that one now we're just okay so
we've got different one
Thank You coach the signs anyway then
catch the kettle firstly application
seventeen three two one six REM is in my
ward I will therefore be sitting out for
that one North arm Charrington there was
a previous application on this site
where the applicants agent wrote to me
concerned about process within this
District Council which I passed on to
the leader and I think had a planning at
the time but I have not other than
having a copy of the flyer for this
document I haven't had any input into
this application or any knowledge of it
[Music]
number ten application 18 confirmed
you're seeing that up here in that
application with the night I can look at
that no clear I haven't finished yet
application to eight eight three was my
form award it is no longer my award but
I'm just recording that for the record
but I'm quite happy sitting on that
application as well anybody else
thank you very informative eventually
once we got there minutes
are you happy but confirmed from
Arkansas in the minutes of the meeting
Howard on the 12th of December and the
16th of January thank you right we'll
move on to item 4 which used to do
standing group yeah I did mention both
on cancer kettle 1257 Batman and the
16th of January we where you're happy
today item number for a steering group
guidelines please no sorries it's not
this one item number four is to do with
steering group guidelines
Thank You chairman item for the agenda
relates to the guidelines for the
operation of steering groups where they
are established by a planning committee
chairman the recommendation is that the
guidelines for the operation of steering
groups as details on page 18 of the
agenda are endorsed thank you I'm happy
that excuse me that to propose that we
endorse the guidelines against
abstention one Jen Thank You committee
those two agree the endorsement of
guidelines for the operation of the
steering groups as per the report now
we'll move on to item five councillor
kettle which is 17 / 0 3 2 1 600 M for
Mijares Network Station Road bishops
Edgington thank you I will step out at
this point can I also add as you know
I'm a farmer in this district I
therefore know many of the farmers many
of the landowners it's just district I
do know the applicant for that one I
refer to anyone okay thank you
Alyce's are presenting personas on thank
you as detailed in the update sheet
bishop switching to imperishable
councillor Harris and councillor kettle
have all withdrawn their objection
as a result again as detailed in the
update sheet the recommendation has
changed that in accordance with the
council Constitution it is now
recommended that the application be
delegated to for approval offices Thank
You chairman Safari I want to speak on
this
by all means Chow sport you can start I
was going to propose that we yep because
I I'm happy that to propose that we
delegate this ripsaw I've got stupid
[ __ ] at this committee report this
application to offices I'm gonna seek in
a second on this so yeah I've got
proposal second that's so unhappy you
can get a vote on this one
all those in favor for to what those
against abstentions one chairman thank
you welcome back Casa kettle
I'm jealous
all right we'll move on to our next item
on the agenda which is application 18 /
0 3 2 3 9 if you are feel between dog
rain and files lying on the hill now
presenting officer is Matthew Thank You
chairman so the application relates to
land to the east of fells lane it's on
the eastern side of the village of
Knutson on the hill Falzone is a narrow
track which leads from dogs Lane just to
the bottom of the site here through to
the vicarage Road just above the black
dot on the center of the screen so the
red line shows the the land as part of
this application this site contains
agricultural land at the moment and
there's notable changes across the site
there's a public footpath which runs
along the southern boundary the site
towards dog Lane and there's one to the
north of Siler runs across the chakra
road is there's no listed buildings as
it's not in the conservation area but it
is within the RSA Hills special
landscape area this is an aerial view of
the site the site beings or weather
cursor is now on the screen but this is
fells lane which connects through from
dog Lane here through to Vicarage Road
at the top this part of the land here is
currently under development for
residential units and the site itself
has an access off this side of fells
lane in the form of a gate so this slide
shows the draft bill severe boundaries
for naps and so these are in draft form
at the moment so you have a limited way
but it just shows of where the boundary
is that we've drawn up at the moment
which is a long sort of the fells lane
here there's a wooded area here which
has been excluded from the be UAV I
would have come to the same conclusion
that the sites outside of the built of
area boundary and I'll show you some
photos of that in a moment
so this is the
host site location plan it shows a
two-story dwelling in this location a
workshop and a garage sort of Venus the
form of an agricultural shared for the
storage of classic cars
the proposals also include some up
gradients to the track which leads in
from the north side of the fells Lane
this is the proposed dwelling so it's a
brick built construction it's got a
solar slate roof and these are the
elevations for the the classics car shed
and the workshop as some floor plans up
here this is a view looking southeast
towards dog sled dog lanes or you can
see a car in the distance they're sort
of using dog Lane which contact connects
up to shuttle Road which is sort of in
this area over here the lands of beyond
the site isn't partially in an
agricultural use and then there's some
playing fields beyond sort of further in
the distance so this is another view
looking south down fells Lane you can
see the new houses being built out on
the right-hand side and the site being
sort of this parcel of agricultural land
here this is a view looking north up up
hill towards the main settlement of
Knapton and that fails lane the photo on
the left is closer to the the bottom of
the hill and then the right the site is
just sort of on the right-hand side up
here so this is looking from the public
right-of-way this the site sort of ends
just around here and the proposed
warning would be sucked in this location
this is a slightly old photo in the
houses which saw in an earlier photo a
sort of going up in this sort of area in
the center of the screen this is looking
north uphill towards the playing fields
the sites or in the center of the screen
and this just shows so
the changes in levels between fells lane
and the application site this is a bit
further along sales lane where the
public right-of-way is purchase or gives
an idea about the the changes in levels
okay so there's the detailed assessment
of the application signing your agenda
on page 41 there was an update tonight
there was a correspondence received
between the applicants and our
straightening Department just advising
the the waste contractures use fails
lane for what a refuse collection so in
summary the principle of development in
this location isn't considered to be
acceptable and there's no identified
local needs which supports the
development here the design scale in
citing the dwelling would have a
detrimental impact on the character of
the area and the landscape at Castle
Barnes and the the access isn't
considered to be appropriate so it's
recommended for refusal for three
reasons to our on pages 53 and 54 of
your agenda thank you thank you monthly
for persevering through the
interruptions and we'll just move on to
our first speakers which are cancer
Linda quorum and counselor Gordon Clark
from knock tempera canceled
hmm I was just surprised because on I'm
the county councillor for Knapton and
they did indicate they would turn it up
tonight so sorry about that are they
able to get into the building at this
time okay um we'll move on to our next
photo speaker which is so there's
Greenwood and mr. Sanchez please you've
got some slides I believe you will be
speaking first mr. Sanchez will speak
first if you tell him when he's nearly
to a minute and he'll wind down and I'll
speak for the rest of the time so what
makes a minute from mr. Sanchez yeah we
might run over a bit and then I'll pick
up from there okay yep thank you okay
good evening our family have lived
worked and volunteered in our village
community for over 22 years and is now
becoming necessary for us to
future-proof our living suffering from a
chronic disease makes finding a new home
extremely difficult and after extensive
research we've decided on self-build and
will happily agree to an s106 award and
other counselors have been newsy a
Stickley supported us we maintained that
the plot sits within the village
confines and is within easy walking
distance of all amenities but is
practically invisible from
the other roads it is dwarfed by 15
floodlit stanchions on the north bow on
the northern boundary and the new
development to the west which urbanized
is the bottom third of the lane which
could be used as an alternative access
to the plot and by sympathetic
resurfacing would resolve many of the
objections passive houses high standards
deliver almost carbon and energy neutral
homes and a healthy environment one
minute it okay please support our
application and allow our future
proofing to today for us too this is a
local need scheme and a soft build
scheme both of which are supported by
core strategy policies a s10 and CS 15
draft policy air sa p1 and the draft
neighbourhood plan and this includes
adjacent to the built-up area boundaries
not just within it policy a s10
specifically allows for quote small
scale schemes for housing to meet a need
identified by the community in a
neighborhood plan or other form of local
evidence and I quote distress evidence
on land within or adjacent to a village
the 2018 housing needs survey for the
village identifies a need for self build
three-bedroom homes and this is also
supported by the neighbourhood plan you
should not dismiss the survey as the
officer seems to just because houses
have been built by a developer the
survey says that self built houses are
needed the Parish Council cannot be the
sole arbiter of what is local need s10
makes it clear that this is a judgement
based on evidence and the evidence is
there in the housing needs survey as
referenced in the neighbourhood plan
furthermore policy essay p1 although in
draft does allow for soft build housing
adjacent to Knapton this is not open
countryside and Stratford's own
landscape assessment says that the area
has potential for some housing there is
some confusion about the s purpose to
application refuse collection teams
comments
because they don't need to turn on the
lane anymore
we don't necessarily need a turning head
and we don't need to improve the lane as
much as we originally thought we can
negotiate this further if you want if
it's a concern
you could defer the application a site
visit would actually be helpful in this
case anyway we believe we've worked hard
to bring forward a sensitive scheme
which is in the local vernacular to meet
a real local need we hope you can
support the application just two seconds
to spare so good evening it's a pity
that the parish council aren't here
because I noticed in the committee
report that they don't consider the
development meets the needs of a local
needs scheme and say that it does not
have the support of the local community
could you respond to that because
obviously you've mentioned in your
presentation that you believe it is a
local needs scheme yeah I mean we
submitted evidence with the application
of a particular medical need for
adaptable housing and mr. Sanchez and
his family have lived in the community
and owned a business in the community
for over 20 years the parish council
seems to have we think a bit arbitrarily
decided this isn't a local needs scheme
because there is a need it is local and
the housing needs survey says
specifically that two 3-bedroom self
built houses for local people are needed
in the village and these haven't been
built elsewhere so the need remains it's
quoted in the pit in the draft
neighbourhood plan we're not sure why
this doesn't qualify they might object
to some other things about the
application but it does seem pretty
straightforward that meets the local
need qualification
mr. bones I've got to what is similar in
the respective parish council estates
add to the village band that you're
saying it's in the parish fun am I
correct in what I'm saying
the parish council and the officer and
the draft site allocations plan planned
so that it's just outside the village
boundary it's just across the lane from
a site where 28 houses are being built
and as mr. Coyne said but it does show
as being outside so they're entitled to
have that view what mr. Sanchez was
trying to say in this presentation is
that this is an open countryside their
house is on one side there's a sports
club on the other there's floodlit
sports tennis courts above just above
the site it's a matter for judgment in
the end whether it's in the village or
not but the policy allows it to be a
village the other thing was this road
because you're going to improve it have
you got enough places for passing or I
mean do you own the land or available I
mean that looks to be where the new
adstar is not directed to come through
there what I'm saying is you are going
to improve the road there are other
places that is available for passing the
arrow in the plan I think is in the plan
that we've submitted that does show a
passing place to be provided and a
turning head to be provided now those
were to this requirements of the county
Holloway Authority and your own refuse
collection team the refuse collection
that is in in outline what they wanted
their comments on the application were
more about wanting extreme detail about
construction details and drainage yes
the red lines are going running across
it
that's the built-up area so those are
existing houses so what I was trying to
demonstrate is that those line isn't it
isn't just I don't think it's a natural
boundary if anything is the natural
boundary it has to be botlane which is
also the road to Pryor's there's
actually a misnomer the workshop is in
fact a plant room for the Passivhaus so
it's not a workshop it's actually it's a
misnomer I don't quite know words yes
it's a second secondhand agricultural
thing I've got about half a dozen
sometimes about a dozen classic cars so
I was looking for a place that I could
keep them the the actual size of it is
is fairly elastic it's not a business
it's it's my hobby
it's just my Hopi that's all
catch the ball yes this is a built-up
area yes it was it was a bit confusing
on the on the aerial thing because on
the Google thing about so I thought that
one looked better John I could just but
that's the bit I'm just trying to show
where the villages and where fells Lane
lies with in relation to that
yeah Castle kettle in the highways
response they identify the change that
needn't has been need to be made to the
road that might help them remember the
objection but you haven't actually
included
change their application could you
explain why not their their comment
wasn't that they disagreed with the
passing place or the turning head that
we provide it is that they wanted
construction and drainage details to be
submitted
now that's usually something which would
go it as a condition rather than before
a planning decision was made and it
involves considerable amount of further
expense at the same time we were in
negotiation with the council's refuse
collection team who originally wanted
the road improvement in the turning head
but in that turns out that unbeknownst
to their own manager the refuse Lord
goes all the way down fil's Lane anyway
so it doesn't need a toning head it can
collect from the doorstep of this home
mr. green what in any case yeah it's
like confusing there because the street
collection off sees the district council
County Council there's more to do with
their highways so is that awesome
answering your question kettle or do
want to rephrase it different formats
that would help highways are very
specific concerns which you have not
addressed now we could propose to defer
this I don't know many of my colleagues
might support that which would enable
you to submit the necessary details to
the country to enable them to adorn
their objection but we do have an
objection of the state from County which
I think may it's quite difficult also
would you know would you be prepared to
put those things as put the details to
County or not I don't think that I think
this can have to be the debate I think
he's not a Christian not surfer the
applicant but okay I can understand
about the sentiment has come from there
but
I've got one more question behind your
site there is a looking on Google Earth
is rather a you've got a football pitch
to the north of the site and then there
is a barn
something is that within your ownership
Thank You Matthew no no that's that's
just the sort of just a collection of
typical farm buildings I think there's
an original one and then a lean-to on
that and then a lean-to on the other so
in that area to the left of that that's
where I was going to put my secondhand
agricultural building to put my dozen
cars in I think you're free to go gentle
we've the parish council have now
arrived so we will be asking them to
come forward now and give their
presentation so thank you very much so
you're free to go and if you turn this
off
in the middle aisle Gordon Clark from
Knapton Parish Council
sorry bit late we got held up from a bit
of a traffic jam with an accident so
sorry about that I did this offs that
you're not the only one going okay I'm
speaking on behalf of dr. parish council
who strongly object to this application
the application to build on this site
goes entirely against the recently draft
built-up area boundary the site is
outside this boundary to the east of
Latin and located in undeveloped open
countryside development in this area
opens up the opportunity for future
applications outside the built-up area
boundary setting a precedent for
development not recognized and consulted
with Knapton Parish Council and
recognized by the forthcoming
neighbourhood plan the application is
not community led and the cancer were
not part of any consultation with the
applicant prior to the submission of
this application comments on the website
regarding the application list 12
objections and seven supports we know
that two of these support letters are
from people not living within the new
parish
we're also disappointed that our ward
councillor Chris Williams offers his
support to the application what is it
obviously not community supported and
outside the built-up area boundary the
application cannot demonstrate community
support does not have Knapton parish
council support is outside the recently
agreed draft built-up area boundary and
the development would be on versatile
agricultural land summing up this
application does not conform with
policies a s 10 C s 15 and CS 16 of the
core strategy as confirmed by the
recommendations for refusal by head of
planning robert weeks
allowing development outside the
built-up area boundary without public
and parish council consultation would
invalidate the process of voting and
defining the built-up area boundary for
these reasons Knapton council asks that
the application is refused thank you yes
chairman we've heard the applicant
declare that in his community mode and
we've just heard you say that it isn't
now what grounds do the Parish Council
have for saying that this isn't a
community LED screen I believe that
community led schemes and impasse
schemes which all past issues of the
community that are from a consultation
with naps and residents on an open
public display of what's happening
that's community LED as far as we're
concerned when the public or the
residents have napped and have a chance
to see all right well can I follow that
up then has the Parish Council conducted
a housing needs survey in your parish
yes
when can't be quite accurate that with
that one to be honest no I think the
most recent one was March 2018 any
further questions thank you oh okay
Ketel just in time there
in your response you say the application
meets some of the requirements of the
draft SPD for local needs
could you tell us what you mean by the
application meeting some of those
components but not others which are in
and which are out I haven't got it
listed but on the officers report
Robert weeks is listed on his comments
on the website I'm just asking your
comments as a parish you submitted that
does meet some rips into the parish so
could you throw your mind back to when
you made ice I really could not just
peel the corners take it all I know is
if we read if we've obviously read the
policy and see what this applies to it
doesn't meet all of those criteria right
thank you can still comment okay freeze
ago right we haven't got the warden over
here tonight he did send his apologies
and after you see on page 44 that was
his comments he did promise he'd send me
a statement to read out and I was just
checking emails I wasn't looking at
other reason checking emails to see if
he had sent a statement but he hadn't so
I might just add on that interventive I
did see council Williams as a podcast
meeting on Monday evening he receives
treatment on the Tuesday and Wednesday
and often feels extremely poor after
their treatment so I suspect it is that
ya know I do appreciate it's very poorly
he did say you try and I saw him the
last time so we will now move on to
points of clarification to the officer
on page 48 you list the criteria of
eligibility for this type of development
and you accept that the applicant for
this scheme meets the above-mentioned
criteria ensuring that then helps with
regards to look a local need property if
it is within the I suppose 106 rep
criteria so I think there's there's two
issues there if you if the proposal
itself meets the identified local need
and supported by the community then the
applicants do fit the criteria for an
okra needs scheme and they they've lived
in the parish for more than twelve
months their businesses are there etc so
they do meet the criteria but it's
whether or not the proposal is for an
identified local need or whether it's
for an individual need
yes gorgeous flow on that point with mr.
coin please does he have the results of
the local housing needs survey and if so
if so hang old councillor kettle he's
trying to nudge me because there's
something in the report correct there's
something in the report and top page 48
which refers to the details of the
housing needs survey what it advises our
members is that since that survey it's
been undertaken there has been a number
of permissions granted and indeed so
although there is a survey those limited
way attach to the findings of that
survey at this current time by the way
it doesn't help us with conclusions in
respect of whether this is a local needs
scheme or whether this is a scheme for
somebody's personal needs which are
separate considerations
thank you mama similar all the new
houses that have been built that we've
seen they are not addressing what the
parish council survey for affordable
home and wanted is that correct I'm
saying there is still a need as far as
I'm aware that housing was delivered
after the housing needs survey was
undertaken I'm not familiar with the
details of what has been delivered in
Knapton specifically but elements of
that would have met that need there is a
residual requirements I don't know this
time
I think this is a this is lsv - I've
lost it I do have it a minute ago
it is so that that would not I know the
word allocation needs to be carefully
used but that would suggest Knapton
would need something the regional 8080
something has a two houses in the core
structure period I'm roughly there on
time how many houses have been built in
Knapton since beginning the core
strategy period I'm afraid I don't have
that information readily available
counselor at this code time he could
with us the parish can't saw a flyer up
to confirm how many have been built
recently with their laid
don't go so Clarke John to come forward
or cast Goodrem John to come forward so
yeah to give an indication of apologies
chair I misspoke I do have that
information available to me we're okay
now sorry I can confirm that they've
been 26 properties built and 39
properties committed through planning
permissions and that's correct as of the
31st of March 2018 a total of 69
sorry sixty-five dwellings on the
allocate the allocation to use and an
appropriate word is 8 is 80 something HT
- I can't remember council parent will
have it in her core structure and run
for me yes CS 16 yeah so according to
policy CS 16 it would be approximately
700 to total of around no more than 12%
in any individuals settlement so that
would be 84 dwellings
however it's critical to recognize that
that would be within the settlement
rather than outside the built-up area
boundary all right mr. fielding
of the policies that have been are being
built how many of those are local needs
houses in relation to the housing needs
survey are we short of local needs or
social housing without a more recent
housing needs survey I can't confirm
that I don't know and without another
housing needs survey it seems to be a
slight contradiction from the housing
need that the data that has image said
survey which were told about 18 months
ago on page 47 it says that the housing
needs survey with January 2012 which is
slightly more than 18 months ago my
calendars awry
yeah without checking I wouldn't know I
think it's probably the the more recent
the date but without checking I wouldn't
be able to confirm that it is quite
relevant I'm just taking some some
advice
you
members just one thing before we come
back to the housing point and that is
the county objection and as of advice
before on county objections if the
District Council goes against the county
objection then we may be liable for any
accident that occurs if you grant
permission in this case in order to
suggest that so that is something it
must bear in mind that's careful to say
Thank You mr. Nash I think that's
absolutely appropriate I think it is a
balance I just it would be quite helpful
to know could we ask the Parish Council
when they believe the last parish
whether they agree with the report all
of they believe that they've carried her
out well more recently can we offset
sure I think there's two points they
have one is the highway issue which we
need to look at further the applicants
and the county and also with the housing
matters as well we need further details
for the members to assess the
application in response to that I think
what we would ask members to perhaps
consider is that the the offices
assessment doesn't consider this to be
an application site within the village
confines of Knapton if members conclude
to the contrary to that that it is in
their view within the confines of the
village then clearly the numbers of
dwellings which have been committed in
Knapton are a significant issue in your
considerations if members conclude like
in accordance with our recommendation
with the officers view that this is
outside the boundaries of nantan then
housing approved in this location is not
going to contribute towards those
figures anyway so it is a separate
consideration so perhaps members could
have that debate and then if it proves
necessary you could turn to whether or
not the housing figures in that and
support further delivery
careful anyway seeking to contradict
either of you two officers on this
matter I'm just trying to gather the
evidence and right into the housing mid
survey which will I think when we come
to the debate we can then put that into
the balance that's taking into account
your almost advice and David's advice it
would just be nice to know we have a
conflict between 18 months and seven
years with one question is there a more
recent housing lead server and I'm not
confident anything you've said I'm just
saying a little bit of clarification
which we've heard that
can we please clarify that and before we
go into the babe because then we can
discuss it in the debate because we're
waiting for a lot of information I don't
think the information is to hand we've
also got to deal with a highway issue
and therefore we do need some more
information
right after some negotiations or
discussions I'm not happy with the lack
of information and I think we do need to
find some more information on this the
Gardiner County Council knows about the
housing needs and the house and numbers
all would be I would like it if the
committee were able to defer this
application so this information can be
gathered but that is my personal view if
the committee wants to carry on or we
want to differ
whilst we found the housing numbers and
that's committee's decision but that is
the way I would like to go forward but
Kansas ain't yes chairman I'm happy to
second that proposal if that was a
proposal because the situation is I'm
very concerned about mr. Nash's comments
about the county council and the
prospect of liabilities to me the County
Council is a console T not a body that
can veto a planning application and he
seems to interpret it in that sphere
I'm apologize if he feels that I'm
aligning him in that process but however
I've long held the view that the county
have too much sway in the deliberations
of us as a planning authority and
therefore we should note what they say
but we shouldn't be dictated to by them
however that's that's a separate issue
so I would like also in that to see a
copy of the County Council's
observations on this particular
application think
so you're happy to propose that with the
first item can society you and yeah
cancer say you indicated the your how
Peter to second
okay so Katherine yeah I'm I'm not
convinced as an argument for deferment
on this ah mr. chairman holidays are
quite clear they've responded they've
requested information which the
applicant has made a decision that he
doesn't wish to supply the issue about
whether it's within or without the be
UAB it's clear the question is a policy
one whether we as a committee are
prepared to override that policy I think
it's too
along with all these whether it's going
wrong we're sorry
whether there is a recent housing needs
survey the supports the application or
not so it goes but as far as I'm
concerned there's only one question
outstanding and that is is the housing
needs survey of 2012 the most recent one
and that is something which you can't
answer which is why I suggest we Charles
Parish Council there's no other
information we haven't got other than
the one question which I had is when so
most recent housing needs survey is it
18 months ago or is it nine years seven
years ago and if I could have that
answer then I think I'm absolutely clear
we've got all the evidence we need here
we've had the proposal in a second on
this so we'll vote all those in favor
over to federal until we've got all the
information all those in favor for
chairman against one Chairman and
abstention lawn chair so committees
resolves to application due to the
reasons we've discussed
thank you
so move on to our next item on the
agenda which is 18 / 0 3 1 5 6 ful not
farm north on road Charrington new state
dwelling and BB F part 17 on proposed on
poor house with a grand landscape and
ecology enhancement proposals revised
submission of 18 / 0 0 1 so a few Oh
president officer is Matthew Thank You
chairman yes this one you considered the
last east committee see my remember this
some of the presentation i'll go for it
again so the application relates to
north farm which is situated north west
of Cherrington south method west of
brailles
with burrows hill just to the east and
it's southeast of Willington and ships
and style so the site indicated by the
black dots in the center of the screen
there's a road that leads up to the site
which is a classi highway and then it's
bridle way that goes to the north so the
red line shows the land as part of this
application it contains a number of
agricultural buildings an existing farm
house and the land to the the west which
is outside of the application site
contains some ecological mitigation
measures for an earlier permission that
was on the site so the site itself is
within the Cotswolds A and B with the
the western boundary of the site and the
road in the barrio of being the boundary
of that the land to the west of that is
called fringe special special landscape
area that's this scenario of view of
this site you can see the road leading
up to the to the buildings and then the
broader way leading north of that so the
existing farmhouse is where the cursor
is now on the screen and then you can
see the existing farm buildings across
the site this is the proposed site
layout plan so the development includes
a two-story building including a
basement there's a close to develop
around the outside of the 200 ciliary
units there's an office and it
Jim as well as a pool building and it
also includes landscaping with water
gardens around the edge so this is an
artistic impression of the the proposed
dwelling so just give an idea of the
sort of scar the style and scale of the
building and again this is another
artistic impression looking from the
road in regard to this photo this is
just get an idea of the building there
is a hedgerow that will be along this
area in front of the building so it will
obscure some views it's just to get an
idea for the building you can see sort
of browns Hill in the background there
this is proposed ground floor plan shows
that the main dwelling here with the
ancillary recommendation units here and
again the first floor plunger in the
first for accommodation these are the
the north and south elevations so you
can you've got the main building with
the the sort of the police arranged
around on this side in this side this is
a view looking east again an artistic
impression of that proposed pool
building this just shows a comparison
plan between the extant Planning
Commission so that's on the right-hand
side that was approved in 2012 so it's a
replacement dwelling scheme with pool
building in garage and then the left
hand side image shows what's now being
proposed and this is just sort of naval
a so the blue purple lines show the
existing farmhouse with the agricultural
buildings the red shows the extant
Planning Commission on the site and you
can see that overlaid over what they're
now using I'll just run through some
photos this is from the road looking
towards the site and the bride away
you've got the site on the right-hand
side the ecological mitigation as I
mentioned earlier in the in that barn on
the left this is looking in the opposite
direction it turns into bride away just
behind where the photos taken from the
sites on the left-hand side so this is
looking towards the existing farmhouse
you can see browse Hill in the back
and the agricultural buildings to the
left another view looking towards the
west with the main farmhouse and again
just looking from another angle and then
this is just looking out across the site
you can see brows filling backgrounds
just sort of given flavor for the
openness of the site there is an update
on your update sheets and I just
advising you there's some legal advice
on the the report that we've had done
the committee report you've got in front
of you the assessment starts on page 57
if your agenda and it's recommended for
refusal for the reason so on page 75
thank you thank you my fish how about
first speaker type please which is catch
that flip Townsend from Jones and parish
council although again counselor time
zones we've got three minutes and we'll
give you a warning shot with about 30
seconds to go
then when the committee meeting on the
16th of January Highways Department
forwarded the definitive map of the road
to north farm confirming that it is a
public road when kind of public expense
as previously stated our concerns with
this planning application relates to the
access road and preservation of the
existing public rights of why last
November following the repeated request
for the removal of the log a blocking
the road had emerged the owners of the
property were not aware the vehicle
right of access claiming the private use
only in the turf and conversation with
John Clendenin and Warwickshire Highways
he confirmed firstly his approval of the
proposed development is on the basis
that there is no infringement to exist
in public rights of way and he fences
gates blocking or restricting the rights
of why must be removed in accordance
with his letter to the Planning
Department secondly confirmed the site
had not been visited by the highway
department who had just worked off the
definitive map this does not show the
fence interactive along the road
restricting its with blocking the or
blocking the current vehicle turning
area Karen Norton Parish Council asked
committed to consider for areas where
conditions should be attached if
planning permission is granted the first
condition being my immediate
reinstatement of the vehicle turning
area to allocations and specification
approved by the Highways Department the
plan shows proposed tree planting over
the location of the current turning area
picture 3 shows the second condition
being removal of the fence on areas of
the public rights-of-way to reinstate
the historic 30-foot wide that this
ancient riff road setting the statue of
1805 the plans for the landscaping show
nutrient hedge plant and on public
rights-of-way restricting the width of
the road these should also be removed as
condition of a planning as an aside you
can see a new road constructed without
planning permission in this photograph
the third condition being a construction
and management plan to ensure the road
east south the public it should be noted
that tarmac Road is less than a foot
wide passing places have been blocked
off by fencing and visibly obscured by
overgrown bushes for three and final the
consider consider condition ensuring the
public right width of this ancient roof
road remains at 30 foot for perpetuity
with any hedges grass verges and trees
regularly cut back to allow safe access
along the right Road and bridle way the
enjoyment of the future generations at
this area of outstanding natural beauty
this is an ancient drift road or must be
maintained for public use as you can see
in the picture notice there is a new
road that has been constructed running
the other side of that fence and there
wasn't never ever been any planning
application put in for in the Cotswolds
area of outstanding natural beauty thank
you good evening counselor I just wonder
whether you can confirm that you have
absolutely no objection to the
architectural buildings that have been
put before us this this evening and it
is just entirely the road aspect
it is just entirely the road aspect of
it because Lewis said it as we said at
the January meeting we've got no no
objection to the building because we
know you if he doesn't he'll just go to
an appeal and he'll get it on an appeal
anyway sir yes further questions yes oh
yes I can see st. in lincoln's yeah
thank you evening for it you mentioned
in this presentation just now
a 30-foot wide road yet employed but
that was set up by statute yes can you
give us some more details on that
well that was satay in the enclosures
act in 1905 and it states that it will
be a 30-foot drift road between
Charenton and broyles including into the
bottom of Willington Parrish and
Burlington Parrish but as you can see
that the fence has been put up since and
as you can see from those three horses
that are riding there if there is a
vehicle coming down there is nowhere for
those horses to get on the side to let
the vehicle pass or if some use pushing
a pram owned that there right and so the
parish council really would like to see
the back of this bit of fencing is that
right we would like to see that fencing
removed and put back to make the road 30
foot wide or to have it as an open field
as it had been since the 1805 agreement
about eight foot well that is what it
said in the original thing from the 1804
agreement but if it has only been to
that width
has been accepted for some time yes it
has been accepted but it was a it was
always an open fields it was never there
was never no hedges or fence in there
well the trees were there but then if
you saw a car coming towards you you'd
either pull off before you saw the tree
or you would hold the car it slow down
it was it was done as a bit of a prairie
farm yes it was even by the previous
tenant oh by the previous owners but it
was there was never no fencing in there
from that 1805 agreement it's not a road
that took going to go very fast or is it
no and I suspect the number of vehicles
using it on a daily basis is probably
fairly limited it it is not the vehicles
that are used and it is the public that
use it because when the previous person
that owned the farm was living there
there were at least well in the problems
that we that we will clear anything I
think I think we've got this point that
I think we've I think we ought to need
as part of points of clarification for
the offices where it's actually partly
application the ways that side the red
line itself but I think you made it
points pretty well sir and the questions
don't cascade on
correct me on this one so stop me if I
needed stopping I don't often give you
that limitation this application was
heard at the previous planning meeting
and you made concern about a turning
area yeah you haven't mentioned that you
did many I did mention it in the thing
sorry you know I didn't always do my
speech yes I couldn't quite so we just
focus on that tournament
well the turning area is up towards that
listen if you there is a picture of it
somewhere where the original turning
area was its its opposite that listen
hooked
no no well it's not far away but there
is a picture of it because there is a
car backed up on it at the moment one of
them you did show a picture of it
earlier on but as you can see if you
move your cursor towards there that is
where the existing turning circle is
well it was just a slip there that's
where the existing turning circle is it
is C but he is doesn't make any
provision in these plans for or his
landscaping plans for this turning
circle whilst residents have used this a
turning circle is it in fact part of the
public highway yes it was maintained a
public expense the highways tarmacked it
and kept it in order when the previous
owner was there thank you right thank
you cancel time for you to go
and we'll move on to our next speakers
which is mr. Hamilton and mr. Lee they
can gentlemen you've got three minutes
between you you divided it equally or
I'm speaking and one asking without
answering question I'm Craig Hamilton
I'll begin very briefly and then mr. Jo
will take over
oK you've got three minutes between
yourself far away when you're ready good
evening chairman and members thank you
I'm Craig Hamilton and with Martin Lee a
we have already provided you with a copy
of the application presentation summary
pack for the proposed estate house plus
wholly supportive consul T quotations
turning to the summary presentation on
summary sheet a1 shows how the spread of
the semi dilapidated on site buildings
will be replaced by traditional design
which is well represented in the local
area sheet a3 shows the extensive
landscape proposals that will
significantly enhance the a and B
setting and on this point C P re said
the design is of exceptional quality and
can be considered truly outstanding
sheet a4 illustrates the quality of
materials and design detail sheet B
shows the proposed siting of the new
house further away from the bridleway
and with a 39 percent reduction of
on-site building footprint sheet d here
are three examples of traditional power
seventy nine houses of similar or larger
size granted consent in recent years
sheet e sets out a comparison of the
previously consented dwelling with our
proposals and sheet F provides
comparison with the three nearest houses
of similar or larger size on this point
C P re has said the design and materials
are wholly in keeping with kin
houses found in the northern part of the
Cotswolds the tagged peer review the
panel concluded that they have no
hesitation in commending the scheme as
an exemplar worthy of an exceptional
proposal under Clause 79 of the NP PF
now turning to the barristers
supplementary legal opinion as provided
to members he says the failure of the
committee report to acknowledge the
importance of the consultation responses
of natural England and CP re the failure
of the LPA to obtain any expert advice
on the issues of design excellence and
thirdly the officers have for whatever
reason chosen not to produce any expert
evidence on the issue of exceptional
design the barrister concluded I have
little doubt that an appeal against
refusal of Planning Commission would be
successful in the light of the
overwhelming expert evidence that the
design is indeed exceptional with great
respect to this committee chairman the
design is what is from one of the
country's leading and thirty-seconds
award-winning and most acclaimed
architects there is overwhelming
professional neighbor consul T and ward
councillor support from councillor gray
please members can we let common sense
informed by professional judgments
prevail for the grant of this house on a
site which already has consent for a
house that is only 15 percent smaller
thank you spot on any questions building
we've heard from the parish council
about the road leading up to the
property are you prepared or happy to go
along with the requirements of the
parish in allowing that road to be
unguided and providing a turning area at
the top end to meet we will be bound by
any requirements of the County Highway
Authority there are no gates
blocking the road the original the
previous owner had installed gate which
we have moved in terms of the alleged
turning area it's it's within the
consented curtilage of the previous
replacement dwelling it therefore it's
legitimate planning use is part of the
consented fenced off garden to that
property so no we would not go with the
second request that will it will agree
to all matters required by county
highways or county rights-of-way
dimension I think the phrase
overwhelming I might be emotivist
awesome overwhelming neighborhood
neighbors support to this proposal yes
was he seven letters of support and
there's three letters or objections in
the report and two on the update sheet
but so when I said overwhelming that was
all support however it was from
Constantine that's fine that's fine
thank you
yeah but the nearest neighbor has
written to support it other neighbors
there's no neighbor objection in fact
there's no objection from any party to
the proposed house or the landscape
proposals well well okay thank you okay
fine that way the officer is on yeah any
further questions just concerned about
this turning circle are you not going to
allow any wrong to allow people who
drive up that road to be able to turn
around and come back down again all
report
yeah but the attendance Oakland I
haven't got the records in front of me
but if the turning circle is a highway
my terrible at public expense and the
county have a right and the public have
a right to turn in that circle but I'd
like to said I haven't got the details
in front of me
I think we're straying into hollow
matters where we don't need to and if
there's enforcement of highway or
anything under an enclosure Act of 1805
then that is not really a matter for the
this council or this committee careful
do you have any comments to make about
the comment made by the parish about
this being a recognized public access
route from brailles through to
Willington I think was the word what was
the village used I think I think most of
Ashley's just just answered that I just
want just a call I think we've done
things any need to comment on that I
think we'll learn it further so it's any
other questions no thank you gentlemen
Oh for you to go but get the points of
clarification now I'm sure remember oh
what a member sorry catch the gray not
you Sumner walk over here at the moment
so it's good to have one so apologies
for missing your own
the grain okay thank Joan as you know
this is applications for a site which
currently has an existing dwelling which
is now derelict and the site has
permission for modern replacement
building under an application which I
think came from 2012 the replacement
going with their large house with
swimming pool and courtyard garden the
applicant in that case was competent
courts Thornton scorpion estates and the
application was for replacement dwelling
garage and pullout buildings including a
change of use of lands from agricultural
to domestic curtilage the offices report
accepts the principle of development and
establish on the site they found finds
that this application is acceptable in
terms of flood risk neighbor input
neighbor impact ecology highways and
public right-of-way I personally
received a number of emails with
conflicting views about the access road
but I see the report states it's an
adopted highway and neither County
Council highways or rights-of-way teams
have made any objection there the
reports argument refuses application
hinges on the size scale and design of
the buildings part of that argument is
that a modest farmstead is becoming a
grand estate house and the formality of
the courtyard and domestic garden areas
would be discordant I struggle with this
argument as the existing permission for
Compton scorpion estates has already
accepted the inclusion of a courtyard
garden and a swimming pool with in a
domestic rather than Agricultural Cerf
image clearly it is an exceptionally
large house and much bigger than the
existing permitted design there is some
debate over whether there would be an
increase or a decrease in the built
footprint on the site the officer's
report says that there have been
I think is 183 square meters increase
which is against the the existing design
that has been given permission and the
the architects in their documentation
says something like a 39 percent
reduction in the footprint but that is
against the existing buildings on the
site
however CPR he has written report
support of his application who uses an
outstanding country house that sits well
in the setting regarding its impact as a
positive rather than negative feature
that views it echoed by the nearest
neighbor who wrote in support describing
as a home of considerable distinction of
a traditional an unobtrusive Divine
Design which will blend extremely well
into its setting Chairman I support the
application Thank You counselor very
clearly succinctly any questions for
number and did you mention or you
mentioned you had some emails about this
phone from neighbors or did I miss Ella
Kem they're mostly firm members of the
public I'm not sure that their neighbors
and some of them were referring to the
parish councils position which I think
counselor Townsend as those given
details all right we will now move on to
points of clarification any questions
for the offices no well I'm Nicolas by
the highways issue but mister knock
won't let me giggle any more on it
canceling well niggling mr. Nash's is
part of what I hate refers to as keeping
him awake but I'd see that it's
supported by both CP re but also the AO
& B has never recognized the president
would result in some enhancement by
virtue of replacing a very derelict and
rundown form of Fox said it sounds at
the Aon B and the CP re both on page 67
are in support of the scheme or have no
objection to the scheme is there a
question there please so the bit that
your offense is at the top of the last
paragraph on page seventy sixty seven
the last Pro top of the last paragraph
yes yes I think that that was referring
to the fact that this site at the moment
is very rundown and derelicts you can
see the sort of the state of the former
farm buildings on the site and there is
going to be some benefit in clearing the
site but that benefit would be the same
with the extant planning permission
there's no greater benefit by tearing
the site through this application mr.
Feldon so I guess the Brandt section of
79 of the NPP F talks about planning
policies all cuts the power has gotten
from for except the essential need for
world worker but we're not relevant here
not a hurry to data reuse redundant or
disused buildings yes
paragraph II the design of exceptional
quarter in that it is truly outstanding
or inert of it in innovative why your
second case the kettle we have one meet
in please gentlemen find on please and
some time ago after Molly's yards and
others agree that no electronic but
devices in any way should be used by any
other members no that's that's a
slightly different yeah I was there as
well we stopped and yeah if actually
devices are being used for the purpose
of looking up what it says on the end of
all PF or for matters pertaining to this
application that is allowable and I just
kind of kettle it to be doing that some
of those might not necessary be doing
that book hence the kettle already
agreed that he will be doing that I'm
not I trust him to do that so I've got
no issue with case of kettle Hughes than
that so please carry on for the sake of
clarification counselor Barnes I have
two pages open one is this applications
webs web page on the planning portal
okay and the second one is the
definition of paragraph seventy nine of
the NPP f subparagraph I'm totally in
compliance with those rules because it's
entirely relation there's no personal
media on here whatsoever I'm not talking
to anybody about anything other than
extracting information if I can go back
to the point n PPF paragraph here and
I'll use a paper copy if you like Rodney
electronic copy all right carry on carry
on
is truly outstanding or innovative now I
think the applicant has tried to explain
that this is not less sound initative
because it is reflection of a number of
other properties that have been approved
and therefore it's not innovative but
they would claim it as outstanding
what evidence do you have suggests this
is not understanding I think the
officers report really tackles this
issue concluding on page 74 that this is
a scheme that has been designed to high
standards but it's considered that
design does not result in exceptional
quality or design and therefore it fails
to meet paragraph 79 obviously the the
concerns which the authority is officers
are raising is in respect of the scale
of the design in that what's being
proposed is significantly larger than
the dwelling it replaces and the expand
permission what I would ask members to
do particularly those with the MPF in
front of them is also to return and to
paragraph 172 of the NPP F which
provides an approach to development
within our areas of outstanding natural
beauty which says that we must give
great way to conserving enhancing those
landscapes and the scenic beauty of them
and that the scale and extent of
development within those designated
areas should be limited and Planning
Commission should be refused for major
development other than exceptional
circumstances and this new development
within a OMB should really be in the
public's interest and a detrimental
effect on the environment the landscape
and recreational opportunities really
should be at the forefront at members
considerations that's what the case
officer's report
tries to strike a balance between the
extant permission and what's being
proposed and the conclusion is that this
is significantly larger to such an
extent that it's harmful to the a OMB
and therefore it conflicts with the NPP
F policy cs20 a is 10 CS 15 and so on
okay and again Vince's points of
clarification I'll just emphasize the
fact that I've got no issue is Planning
chair of each committee with councilor
kettle using an electronic device during
this application because he's using it
to gain information that will look at
information
is pertinent to this application he
would have been looking at the football
scores or Facebook or something else I
would have taken a different you but
I'll just counselor kettle to use this
sensibly and reasonably so I've got no
problems about cases yes well as you
can't see his machine and I can I
thought I would just confirm that you've
deduced things correctly just to confirm
that a few minutes ago his phone lit up
and he quickly turned it over to ignore
whatever it was so presumably the things
you wouldn't want it to do he is
ignoring make sure people are paying
enough attention and listening to the
debate and listening to others rather
than being distracted by various items
on social media so so just happy to
clarify that and make that a point of
clarification
okay so kettle may I suggest I'm
delighted that you what you also focused
as a committee on my behavior and I'm
glad to say like there's nothing to do
with the sexual application can we
return to the application and going back
to your comments about paragraph 172
about public interest in this I'm not
quite sure on some t2 says that so
there's got to enhance a setting it
doesn't it doesn't exactly require the
public to be calling all over a relation
of Blenheim Palace and what we're
talking about here is actually size
scale and the quality of design I think
which it was the only reason for refusal
yeah
rather than I don't think the public I
don't think you can you can tell me why
the public need to be so interested in
the cause yeah absolutely if you'll
before bear me I'll read directly from
the NPP F when it talks about a on these
it says the scale and extent of
development within these designated
areas should be limited planning
permission should be refused for major
development other than in exceptional
circumstances and where it can be
demonstrated
development is in the public interest
that's paragraph 172 all points of
clarification I think we've done rather
well their ticket should we move on to
the debate case the Perry Thank You
chair been waiting very patiently
actually and I haven't contributed my
normal bit this evening because a number
of questions have been answered before I
feel what we have in front of us is a
unique planning application it's very
rare that we have something that comes
before the committee that is on such a
scale but has been so carefully thought
through and when you look at what is
currently there the derelict buildings
there's also an extinct permission in my
view it totally hits every button on
paragraph 79 I believe it is a design of
exceptional quality I think it enhances
that whole particular area we have no
objections from the County Council we
have support from the ward member the
Parish Council understandably they have
some issues regarding the rights-of-way
area but they have no objection to the
quality of the design and that has been
very clearly made so from where I'm
sitting I'd like to propose that we
grant permission for this application
that's the site I can see your prime
speaker right I think the the one
question mark that I have in my mind
in view of what David Jeffries just read
to us from the MP
PF is this question of whether this
particular proposal is in the public
interest because I tend I'm inclined to
dismiss the officers recommendations
that this is not exceptional I think
this proposal is considerably better
than what was referred to as the Compton
scorpion proposal which was presumably
the previous approval I better be
careful what I say because I know the
the master of compiègne Scorpius say is
quite well so I don't want him to think
I'm misquoting him so consequently we
have a situation whereby the judgment is
quite strongly in favor in my view for a
long time up to 2017
I was the County Council for this part
of the world and and I stood down in
2017 and I also from 2004 up to that
time sat on the management board of the
Cotswolds Conservation Board as indeed
does councillor gray even to this day I
do believe again I had to stand down
when I ceased to become a county
councillor but the situation is this
that I don't think there's anything in
the O and B management plan which would
argue against allowing one isolated
dwelling of this size of stature the
ones nearby are Birmingham Grange and
Charrington Hill I think it's called
which are also big houses of similar
size but they're sufficiently far away
to have a reasonable degree of
separation between those those country
buildings and therefore I know the
conclusion that we have to overcome the
policy point of view of is this in the
public interest well I think we could
perhaps get some help from colleagues on
this but my
could be that he ought to be in the
public interest in that he tidies up the
site I'm sure we can deal with the
highways issues and rights away issues
that Philip Townsend referred to outside
the planning application I think he's
made his point and he's a gentleman I
have no of old from my days as County
counselor and effectively
he will dogged Lee stick to a point that
he believes to be correct and I'm quite
well prepared to believe him but there
was some statute in 1805 that said there
has to be an open nature of this tract
or Road however if the County highways
metal it up to even eight feet wide then
that's a signal that it is a public
highway maintained at public expense and
I'm quite prepared to take their word
for it all the words for it what was
said I personally think that this is a
huge improvement on the previous
application and therefore ought to be in
the public interest because it will tidy
up a site at a location it's not viewed
by many public because I know from my
days as County counselor that property
is in that area are fairly sparsely
spread about they don't that's not a
there is probably about ten I should
think within a mile radius of this
particular site and effectively they are
all going to be in a position where
they're largely unaffected by it unless
there's some traffic problems and I
doubt that and I think the turning Bay
is going to be there under the plans if
we approve them so I'm quite happy to
support this application in all its
glory building and Khosla I agree with
my other than my two colleagues the view
from the AO and B of that prairie land
which has been all the fences remove
to have something of this nature and the
concept of the other areas they're
wanting to develop I think he's very
beneficial to the area and I think it
will enhance what is a rather dreary
looking set of old buildings and I must
admit I didn't think much of the other
plans that was going forward so I'm in
favor and I'm prepared to second Perry's
Tesla bombs yes if far as I'm concerned
about an application whether all the
people that usually complained the CPRA
and and that's actually for it I did go
and look at it some months ago it is an
untidy side I'll fully support what's
been proposed
I think the CP re a clear message that
this is an outstanding building and I
also believe that the extent of planting
that's been indicated on the applicants
earlier slide from the conical point of
view is of benefit I think there are
footpaths at the top of Brown's Hill
where quality of the planting will be
being planted again which is a public
benefit so I think it would be helpful
if we could come to some compromise to
keep the village of Carrington
comfortable with the plan and whilst I
believe the road is not tarmacked from
the building all the way through the
brownouts in fact never has been and
it's not possible by vehicles have to
stop that if there could be some
compromise whereby some ability could be
made for vehicles to turn I think that
would be up to officers to tell us
whether that could be included as a
condition change I think unfortunately
to plan in front of you is informative
in this respect in the application we're
dealing with today is bound by that red
line area there which saw before in
Matt's presentation a plan which showed
the area of land owned by maintained at
the authority's expense and from what I
could tell from that plan it didn't
include an area sufficient to provide a
turning circle either
so if members were minded to overturn
the officers recommendation at this
stage I think they would be difficult
for officers to seek amendment to the
plan or impose a condition which secured
a turning area the plan before members
is one they must consider in that
respect yes a cover would you want to
come back and then Cass lemon and I went
around the world doing man what I turn
around on I don't know but it was a
tarmac I mean other news land it was but
it was a turn in place so if I could
just provide little commentary on this
plan the key shows us that the land
within Brown Colin there is the land
maintainable at the highways expense so
effectively that's the area in which
they surface it and provide facility for
vehicles to traverse it everything else
which was in the red line previously is
within the applicants ownership
ownership that they would be able to
provide amendment to the boundaries of
the highway it's not part of this
planning application in the current time
thank you David um mr. Nash I can't ask
you again could would it be possible to
ask the applicant whether they might be
prepared to accept some form of
compromise in relation to enable cars to
be turned around as a very very moment
minor amendment to this or because I
think that would clear the way for
council Saints concerns well just to a
neighbor sorry just to enable the parish
council to be comfortable if we could
make a minor tweak at this stage through
some condition which the applicant might
or might want repair to accept I think
we work because think an appeal there is
a turning circle which is highway then
it can be enforced through the highway
authority if there's no turning circle
and it's actually within the consented
land then they don't have to have
attended circle and we shouldn't
condition it no except I was just going
to ask whether we might be able to ask
the applicant whether they might be
prepared to accept a writ is just
reverse a vehicle in turn should
actually assess what's in front of us
catch the band's complain that this talk
of the circle which is just come on
highways are happy with the proposal
well it said no objections yeah I think
we need to committee minded to go
against officers recommendation I think
we need to make sure we've got our
reasons the policies that we're going to
to be using to grant this application
and any conditions that we're going to
pose or us to be so I think we'll defer
to David on conditions we should all be
doing it obviously bearing in mind
conditions have to be reasonable and
force more as a job you German my view
is that this application conforms to
paragraph 79 of the MPP F without doubt
and 172 because appeal it's in the
public interest in enhancing that
particular area of the village yep okey
doke to realistic conditions please yeah
in respective conditions your officers
would recommend the usual time limits
for full planning application and
development to be in accordance with
plans materials to be submitted and
agreed in so as currently on site pre
commencement condition in respective
land can contamination a condition for
land remediation condition to secure a
full and proper landscaping scheme to be
implemented condition requiring electric
vehicle charging points for the
residential dwellings condition
requiring the provision of bins a
condition requiring mitigation
ecological mitigation to be submitted
and retained there after removal of PD
rights to avoid unplanned extensions and
in the interest of the and tied at the
ancillary accommodation remains
ancillary with the final wording and
numbering of those conditions to be
agreed perhaps between officers and the
chair of this committee
you happy those conditions cases well no
chairman I'm wondering why David Jeffrey
has recommended that we have a condition
on landscaping I thought that the
landscaping of the site was covered by
the application that we have been or
we're adjudicated on and secondly I have
concerns about the removal of PD rights
because it could well be that some small
extension was desirable I agree that if
you remove PD rights they would have to
come back to the committee to be
approved but on the other hand we can
get a bit you know stressful about this
I think yeah I'm happy to come back on
those points the proposed landscaping
condition I would think would be to
secure the details as proposed and to
ensure that they were properly
implemented at the first available
planting season and if there were any
plant failures and so on that they would
be replaced in proper course the PVV
rights removal is considered necessary
because this would now be becoming a
residential property with a substantial
curtilage there's the potential there
for four significant outbuildings and
then I'm mindful that members have
elected to resolve to approve this on
the grounds that this is an exceptional
design so we wouldn't like elements of
that to be watered down or to be
impoverished in some way by future
amendments to the scheme and because of
the a and B there is an exceptional
circumstance which suggests that perhaps
speedy relaxed removal in this
circumstance would be appropriate under
somavia C bonus and then that so we kind
of proposed over for a second we've
agreed what conditions all those in
favor of granting this application
unanimous chairman
yep committee resolves to grant
application 18 a short break for two
minutes two minutes came to the fielding
if you could be back by 8 o'clock
thank
right we'll now move on to the next item
on the agenda which is 18 / 0 0 0 1 ful
up or grow farm roadway Road a loti so
eruption of to an end to support exists
in question Enterprise removal existing
mobile home tax or general store and
office completion of darling yep
scoot to please thank you Joe thank you
Joe
Thank You chair the application so it is
situated with an inert within an open
countryside location a property 680
meters to the north east of the village
of lower torso the site forms part of
the wider upper growth farm which
equates to approximately 26 acres as
indicated on the black dot before you
the soil is used for in the existing a
coin library business and comprises of a
number of associated buildings and
cities including stabling stories
accommodation plant room office
temporary storage containers and
associated pilot land and Ryan schooled
area in addition it is noted that the
side consists of a temporary rural
workers dwelling which was granted by
appeal in 2012 the site sits directly to
the northwest of radaway Road where
access is taken the access Drive runs
along the southern boundary of the site
and leads to an area of high standing
which currently serves the business and
temporary dwelling the soul is in rural
rule in appearance and is surrounded by
fast agricultural land
Delaine lead by dense hedgerow and tree
dying boundaries in this instance a
mature tree bulk forms the southern
boundary of sorry in addition the
application is adjacent to the Cotswolds
area outstanding natural beauty by that
if you can see before you the farmstead
there across the road is the a OMB the
farm itself isn't situated in you a and
B or C does affect the setting
this application seek permission for the
construction of a new permanent rural
workers dwelling in order to replace the
existing mobile home and temporary
containers currently used as a tack
store general store and an office the
dwelling is proposed to be used in
connection with the existing business
and will contain a combination of both
residential and commercial accommodation
as you can see before the plan for you
it demonstrates where the dwelling is
going to be proposed to be sited this is
a dryness location the outline here
shows where the data store indicates the
existing caravan and mobile home and
this is a stable block there and the
farm yard before you the resistant plant
room
situate here would be retained as part
of the application the joinin has a
simpler rectangular platform running
perpendicular to the access drive and
will be finished in natural Horton Stowe
priority code aluminium guttering and I
employed an external ventilation leaves
this is another elevation the other side
same planter and Horton stone and also
the two Baker's to the east as part of
the floor plans a new office will be
located on the ground floor adjacent to
a bedroom and ensuite bathroom and which
will provide residential accommodation
for existing member of the staff the
remainder of ground floor will provide
an open-plan kitchen living and dining
area and a touch single storey double
garage first floor level the joylynn
which will provide three bedrooms one of
which benefits from an ensuite and
family bathroom these are 3d views of
the indicative outlook as a building if
planning permission was forthcoming
as you see before the photo before you
this is the entry point into the
farmstead if the application was
approved the dwelling would be
approximately sighted they're just in
front of the farmstead from the road
this is the access road onto it across
from the road alas to the AO and B point
which is heavily guarded by hedgerows
but the present is he exists in mobile
dwelling which is users were all workers
dwelling as was granted plantation in
2012 this is the actual application site
the dwelling would be situated in this
pastoral land
obviously the rural workers dwelling
would be removed this is a farmstead
itself you see the storage containers
and various options on the farm and the
equine business is taking place there
that's the end the presentation officer
recommendation is full refusal based on
the viability the scheme from
agricultural consultants there are no at
de jure thank you Joe
first speaker please which is cancer
tongue from Tysoe parish council thank
you for bearing windless skeleton
you've got three minutes
we start again well let you start again
thank you
technology at MIT on Monday night we
revisited this application and parish
council asked me to attend this meeting
to support the application the
applicants on this land was 1516 years
she obtained planning permission for
stapling an arena
12 years ago commenced a commercial
business 10 years ago she submitted a
planning application for the change of
use of the stabling to commercial livery
stroke stirred and change of use of land
for the stationing of an essential Ike
wine workers mobile home for a period of
three years this was allowed on appeal
in 2012 seven years ago prior to the
submission of the present application
the applicant sought advice on a preamp
in nineteen twenty seventeen the cashed
Parish Council was supportive of the
present application but we objected only
on materials proposed we wanted Horton
stone under a slate roof we also wanted
an Ag ty landscaping light restrictions
we are also mindful not to appear
vindictive or petty in light of the
appeal inspectors decision going against
the council we didn't want to sort of
have another go we refer to the Kern on
agricultural consultants statement which
says although the enterprise has not
developed to the level envisaged there
remains a functional need to live
on-site a statement endorsed by for
shires veterinary practice in their
letter dated the 4th of February
kernan also stayed in an additional
comment having reviewed additional
submitted information it would appear
that the recent accounts demonstrate
that the business is financially viable
all this appears to be because one of
the financial years in the pier they
considered was lower than it perhaps
ought to be but perhaps we ought to say
that during that period the applicant
took her eye off the ball in nursing her
dying mother so she wasn't really
concentrating on that in any case I
think really if if one financial year in
a farming business was to closes then I
suggest half the farms in South Warren
would be disappeared sorry 30 seconds
left
sorry the planning effort has compiled a
fair report that seems to be saying in
his recommendation it's a tough call so
over to you your counselors on the
planning committee for a pragmatic and
reasoned decision please remember that
the human costs of your decision today
it could trigger the loss of the
applicants home business and effect even
her daughter's education at the local
village school it's very important I
think the the planning planning officers
I think of okay the stone and the slate
as we saw on those amended plans the add
time landscape and we part of the
conditions we hope you mentioned the
Kernan's
letter Conan's opinion and also the
letter from the veterinary surgeon yet
he just
because those details can or noticin
think about the 4th of February was the
letter the letter from the veterinary
surgery was dated the 4th of December
for this episode and it said it's
written to the applicant
dear Deniz Deniz keeps horses and Apple
Grove Farm both her own and provides
livery for members of the public there
are young horses are mares in foal
continually at the premises and those
and so therefore it is a requirement for
the welfare of the animals that someone
lives on site please do not hesitate
upon further information can you just
mention the comment about curtains again
you mentioned about the case in their in
their statement they more or less states
as I say although the enterprise has not
delivered the level envisaged there
remains a functional need to live on the
site and this is enforced by the vet
research they also go on in a later some
later information was put forward and
they say it in this case in the
additional comment having reviewed
additional submitted information it
would appear that the recent accounts
demonstrate that the business is
financially viable so that's great I
just wanted to car I thought I heard you
say that but I didn't quite so you've
clarified that'sthat's great
yes it is a viable situation ok thank
you counts the saint yes can you give me
any indication whether the parish
council have made any comment or have
any reflections on the size of the
proposed oiling no it does it's it's
multifunctional I suppose it's at home
it's an office its accommodation for one
of the groom's
and it has parking that's it any further
questions
no thank you cancel it song you're free
to go
Vanessa I'm sending Deniz Neal the
applicant to come forward said you've
got three minutes between you ladies who
are you to like them equally or
something species only to leave their
questions
witness 30 seconds there that's
brilliant
and so the first thing I really wanted
to cover with them the business in a
kind of short summary the land was
purchased 16 years ago in 2003 and the
business was established 12 years ago on
the site in 2007 in that particularly
year which was covered by Joe there's
the den set up the equestrian area and
had consent for a storage band for feed
and materials an investment made at that
stage was around about 60,000 pounds
into the site and into the business and
in 2012 as joe said existing temporary
rural worker drone was was granted where
the business was seen as financially
viable unacceptable in this location at
that time and since the business was
established twelve years ago it's grown
and the information that we have
submitted and demonstrates that and the
business currently provides full-time
employment for two members of staff and
part-time employment for staff who cover
weekends and the business is integrated
within within the community and
currently holds a waiting list for
livery services can we move slides
Thanks and the next slide just gives it
it's just a snapshot of a planning
timeline where in September 2012
temporary rural worker dwelling was
granted and five years later I'm a
pre-application was made for a permanent
dwelling with the workers accommodation
which the initial feedback was positive
further to that and a full application
was submitted in January 2018 a year ago
I was part of his process local
authority commissioned the desperate
desk based prayers or by Conan's country
for countryside consultants and further
to the consultation process amendments
were made to the external wall facing
material which was submitted to the
local authority and there been no
further objections to this the design of
the new building the consultant was a
appointed by the client which was G
Herbert banks to look at the current
current financial status of the business
further to the comments raised by
Kernan's
and this report concluded that in light
of new accounts which Kernan's didn't
have originally the businesses showing
signs of growth and is profitable and
Kernan's submitted a response in review
to that and stating that in their
opinion there was insufficient
information regarding the financial
stability of the business and so in
summary there were two concerns
regarding the application will change
slide 13 30 second and the first one is
there's an isolated location of the
dwellings so obviously we've established
there's a need for the business within
the local local community is it's
demonstrated by the longevity and growth
of the business and the integration of
the business within the local community
and the initial report produced by
Kearns confirmed that's a functional
need for a permanent building on site
and the second thing is a financial test
and the original report that was put
together by Kernan's was a desk based
assessment it wasn't and there were no
site visits no consultation no
discussions with the business owner
where the second report by T Herbert
bangs there was for nickname I think
we're about to ask some questions that
have I've read them right any questions
catch the balance first
you had the mobile home approved on
appeal
you now want something bigger why is
that something more permanent the new
accommodation which is essentially a
three bedroom house with workers
accommodation also includes and it
includes the mobile and home that is on
site and it also includes the tax store
and storage that and we're more
buildings on site and they're all
brought together in one unit to include
a double garage the current sort of said
that your business isn't quite my
interpretation of what was said by the
Planning Council but you it is growing
with the first application for the
temporary dwelling there were a forecast
of the business park has attached to
that and at the time that wasn't
achieved with the new applicant in the
time of the new application and that was
due to the personal circumstances that
they had in their family society yes
chairman I'd like to explore this
business of the facilities in the
proposed dwelling because my
understanding is a rural workers
dwelling is just that yet you're
implying that it takes on board a
workers accommodation as well as a
three-bedroom house and also some form
of office space and some facility from
the mobile home which we were told was
going to disappear can you be specific
about that please and on the site at the
moment they've got various stores and
attack stars and grain stores and food
stores that will then move into the the
new building on the ground floor we've
got the rural workers accommodation
which is for one person which includes
the office to run the business it
includes and
stars and storage and on the on the
first floor its accommodation for the
applicant at the moment a rural worker
does live in the mobile home with the
applicant
she's very tight cozy okay thank you so
if we were to approve this you
conditioned him removed the mobile home
would be suitable
and profit yeah just trying to lean on a
bit further is that obviously the 1617
and though we're looking at 1718
accounts so obviously we know in 2019 I
just wondered when their counts have
been we're up to whether we've got a
more definitive figure from the
accountants we're just ready so I guess
the accounting period is November
okay yeah so basically that was saying
it was on track to make a profit of
excess of 20 K 20 paise no I think
you're free to go ladies and I hope
you're coughin voice gets better sex
I've I've I've won this one
Oh move on to an award number we won't
forget cancer fielding this time good
evening Kansas I'm sitting here I'm
sitting up for you the reasons why I
believe this application should be
granted this is a stunt film that has
been in operation since I was seven and
approval was given in 2012 20 left 12
for accommodation on site Pratt at that
time there had been several break-ins
and theft's
and therefore the planning for the
temporary accommodation sorry with the
temporary accommodation running out the
owner decided to apply for a permanent
structure subjects and act I the
granting of the application will allow
for improvements to the yard as various
cabins are to be removed within with
their uses being incorporated within the
new building eg tack room offices dry
food store there is also a full-time
groom who must live on the site the
application the enterprise comprises
Shetland mares and stallions American
Quarter Horse is met and uncut coasts
and 35 years there are also eight
part-time livery the value of stock is
between 80 and a hundred thousand pounds
as the market for Shetland pony is not
strong miss neele is diversifying into
American Quarter Horses and can if
necessary demonstrate them at share
miss neele trained as a palliative nurse
and as she looked after her mother in
the lated last years of her life she
nursed her as well as running the stud
and looking after her daughter therefore
she could not give her full-time
commitment to the enterprise
the planning grants for support which is
taken from the officer's report includes
the business was previously considered
financially and environmentally
sustainable and it's now diversifying as
a farm the enterprise the end Qin
enterprise is appropriate use for the
land there is a central permanent need
for an on-site presence of a skilled
worker this underlined by her vet
paragraphs 79 of the MPP air states that
the local planning authority should
avoid isolating new homes in the
countryside unless there are Pacific
circumstances which include an essential
need for a rural worker to live
permanently at or near the place of work
policy a s-10 of the core strategy lists
the form of development and use in the
countryside which are acceptable in
principle with regards to the
residential development is 10 acres the
guidelines contained with the NPP F that
states in Perm a a permanent dwelling
for the occupation of a person engaged
in agriculture operations or other forms
of use other than read sorry forms of
use then can only reason to be carried
out in the countryside subject to a
financial functional need being
established this is an acceptable
principle also highlighted enas tenkan
first to the community and the effects
on the development within the landscape
miss Neil's daughter attends a local
school and she miss neele has been very
much part of the community also and also
the Aon B has not raised any concerns in
the original consultation in May
nineteen sorry something to make 2018
Kenneth was satisfied there was a
functional use for the application that
constant the consultants have confirmed
there is a need for a new dwelling to be
located on the site to ensure the
welfare of the stock is maintained
throughout therefore after invest
investigating the inter entirety of the
site and the evidence of stand by the
applicant the planning office concluded
there is a functional need to establish
a new dwelling on the site for the
erection of farmworkers dwelling to
support the enterprise at Apple Grove
Farm although there is no longer a
specific test in the PNP PA or the
district councils Stratton core strategy
regarding profitability in relation to
the provisions of a rural dwelling the
framework only promotes sustainable
development in rural area paragraph 79
economic sustainability and the ability
to carry out the proposal as described
must be part of this assessment in
conclusion it's very importantly under
Pride based on valuable livestock is
always well to supervise and the owner
living on site miss neele recognises
that have that her breeding stock of
Shetland ponies are not as far as they
used to be therefore she is investing in
a new stock hence the quarter horses she
is also looking into renting more land
however if there is cancer building yes
some more please one paragraph if this
application is turned down her business
will collapse due to lack of on-site
supervision which would cause the
problems of the breeding mares and also
vandalism thank you very much for the
ward member place the bonds in your
comments you were concerned about the
design you've obviously spoken in full
support looking as a barn
rather than as a cottage and I wanted
the cottage look which has now come
about with the current design good no
further questions your free to go case
the fielding thank you but move on to
points of clarification
any points of clarification Chancellor
Perry Thank You chair can the officers
advise or confirm that had Kernan's
confirmed that they felt it was when
they when they spoke to them that it was
financially viable would they would they
be in support of grant that's the major
consideration that they've got yes
officers sought advice from Kernan's on
two occasions on the first reply they
raised concerns about labour and
discrepancies in the report and lack of
variable costs but in their in their
second reply they advised that they were
not able to reach conclusions that the
business was financially viable as they
didn't have the necessary information in
respect of a number of emissions you
expect to see a full set of accounts the
breakdown of all income and expenditure
some of that information was available
but they haven't demonstrated clearly
that the business is financially viable
and therefore they couldn't confirm that
this was a sustainable long term can I
just come back on to that was the
applicant was that information referred
back to the applicant in order to firm
up any further financial info I can
confirm that we did request to the
applicant who wish to submit more
information and we came to the
conclusion it would have to go to
committee from your conclusion in your
report
is somewhat different to the 8th to the
response Institute Council to an
application in Clinton Parish Council
which remember came up here for an
equine dentist who wanted to build a
house next door for stables because he
needed to be that look after the stock
and your colleague some winners her
recommendation was to grant that
application I think there was an
objection for the parish council so it
was it came up here and I'm pretty sure
this cap when this council support the
officer recommendation how can we have
one application a proposal to Grant and
five miles away we have a proposal to
refuse for almost identical reasons
breathing versus that quite industry
I couldn't comment on the other
application as he said it was our sense
application wasn't the case officer
involved what I can confirm in this is
and the development management
considerations part 10 when we have to
do our assessment and I mean we've
report back to Kernan's
it does state that we have to do an
assessment on the financial need and
whether it's a viable avoids therefore
it could be considered unsustainable and
therefore against paragraph 79 in the
MPP F for that reason under this
assessment it's been not established
that it's been involved in viability
done or in the business what we're going
forward in the future so on this basis
that was the reason for my
recommendation if I could just elaborate
on that there's essentially two two
tests two steps to the test one is there
a functional need for there to be an
agricultural workers dwelling on the
site does the business case for that
support it in this case I think we're
accepting that there may be a need you
know for a residential property on the
site to look after the horse is but the
business case the viability of the
business on the site at this current
time doesn't suggest that it's a
sustainable business
and our expert advice from Kernan's is
that that sort of threshold if you like
hasn't been surpassed and so their
recommendation is that it's not quite
for the level where we would agree this
is a sustainable enterprise and
therefore it doesn't meet the test set
out in the NPP F and the development
management considerations of a s10 thank
you David and thank you Joe for that can
I just make one comment though there was
a report I think from their accountants
which I have tried to look up what and
say we have an application in Loxley
which is referred to the response to the
Colonel's report which is not helpful
nothing to this application can I just
record though if we are going to have
documents received I know it's not in
your packet but please could you take
the message back but it's hopeless if we
don't have the right information in
front of us no this is this is Tyson so
it's a little bit difficult speaking as
an accountant with champing an
accountant I know we both like to delve
into figures so it's very difficult to
comment
unless we have that information in front
of us are not professing a deferral
because I think we'll have to show that
in the debate anyway thank you for your
comments everyone okay thank you any
other points of clarification right
should we gone through the debate okay
so say that I can see you're eager to
yes I'm finding this one a bit taxing
we've got a recommendation to refuse yet
the Parish Council obviously and the
ward member are quite keen on this
application being granted and when we
look at the evidence before us we see a
temporary building which we're told the
applicant and the rural worker
living and then we're told that the
applicant has a daughter at Primary
School so presumably the daughter lives
there as well which is going to make it
rather cozy as I put earlier on with
apologies if I've got that wrong okay
now I haven't got it wrong good okay so
so basically I think the people concern
EADS some relief from that situation
what we have got before us though is a
building
don't mind the garages being stuck on
the end but effectively we've got quite
a large building which incorporates a
tack room and a feed room now I would
have thought the tack room and the feed
room would have been in the in the main
livery building the stable block so to
speak which is where I presume a lot of
these mayor mayor's are that are
effectively involved so I would I would
have expected in my experience that a
room on the end of a stable block would
have been the tack room but I know that
to be the case from personal experience
that this is how the things are being
organized so therefore I have some
difficulty in approving the house that's
put before us because it is more than a
house we have I think perhaps to
consider if a building are there is a
house that our dwelling is put before us
then I think it should be approved
whether it should be approved with one
that contains a tack room and a feed
room as well I've got some doubts about
so that's why I'm in a dilemma I don't
quite know which way to turn mr. kettle
don't kiss the bar even castellane I
would respond to that council st. and
there has been a comment earlier on
there been a number of break-ins to this
site and if you are lucky enough to be
on the police will watch you will see
repeated break-ins of stables of tack
being removed and tight
about horse plus and therefore I think
actually have it yeah having it built in
the house is a benefit about the feed
because rats into it but I'm not worried
about that
you know your accountant farmer with
stables
please Thank You chair interesting
application before us and obviously
focusing on the on the financial
viability of the project the one thing
that slightly concerns me about the
application
I hear what the posh council says I also
hear about the ward member and I'm very
much someone who is in favor of
supporting rural businesses my only
slight concern is I feel that the actual
size of the property is is quite large
and I think I might be more inclined to
support it if it wasn't didn't if it
wasn't quite so large but I still hear
from my other fellow committee members
because as I said before I'm always very
keen to support rural businesses and it
is important to take note of what the
parish council and the walk members say
so I will just reserve my thoughts for a
little bit longer in this big house as
we call it which the ward member was
concerned about to start with no he's
really rural crime if you haven't got
things together he's becoming a major
problem too safe god anything
in even isolated houses in my area now
I'm having everything together in one
place in that respect just help to
safeguard what you've actually working
for and tack is very expensive so in
that perspective there has been bigger
than mama would like with the reduction
in the South the other house and the
taking down of the sacrum and all the
bits around there which he's bought I
think it might be okay in the respective
Colonel's that these many years ago when
they first came on the scene and we
asked them to come on the scene because
we didn't know they're sort of limited
are in on this application
I had an application from ten years ago
where they refused it because the man
hadn't got enough sheep he's only got
about sixty just starting up and said it
wasn't Bible he's now got a thousand so
as far as I'm concerned if the business
grows I could think about going against
the officers recommendation with the
conditions that the rest of the site
with his shades and all the other bits
that are there that's our job so that
was only one large building or large
you'd be like but it will have two sets
of families in there and as far as I'm
concerned the office is in there and
various other parts which are essential
there for the shower room will be in
there which you have to have boil oh now
we don't have to use it but he has to be
there as far as I'm concerned I could
I'm privy to propose approval are you
talking about from experience regarding
the shower room there case of ours
I said you took it from personal
experience to guard the share over there
sorry okay so careful yeah if we look at
the size of the quantity accounts the
ones I'm looking at here okay on the
screen three bedrooms upstairs so we
know there is the applicant and a
daughter living there and an additional
room upstairs and they're downstairs
there is the flat apartment for the room
for the for the groom whatever else it
may be so you've got one spare room is
that overdevelopment or not I'm not
convinced the child will need its own
room legally it will need its own room
at some point in the future be
unrealistic to expect the child to share
with the mother so as one spare room too
many clearly the neighbors and their
responses have said this is a
development not the view shared by the
parish council that this is an
opportunity to build a house in the
countryside of when we've had that
argument reflected many many times
before and must be something we should
consider this is a small BEC wine
establishment at the moment and it was
assumed it was going to get bigger when
the original application went through
the Colonel's had said if you've got
livestock you need somebody there to
look after them regardless so it's a
question whether this could be
conditioned I mean clearly I think there
has to be an equivalent northern
agricultural tie or something to ensure
whether that can be used to ensure that
the ground floor flat which I understand
Joe looking at the picture that we've
got in front of us said because I've got
here needs to be for again for the
agricultural business and not let off as
a
revenue stream I don't know with that
can be a a condition so it's all the
whole properties all tied into one if it
fails then the applicant has got to work
out what know if they're going to do
about it
it needs I completely accept me or
coming from recurrence in 2012 said it
need there needed to be a there was
justification for agricultural workers
dwelling here they're still saying
they're just it's a financial test which
i think is one we've got to toss up with
I'm not in any way saying you're wrong
Joe I think it's it's a matter we need
to address as to whether it is liable to
be viable and I think just said 26 acres
loser size it does say in the report I
think some of those births plenty of
land if you have an animal there are any
Shetland ponies or one acre animal would
be cuts the barns more than more than
adequate I think there is the potential
to go ahead even though they haven't
demonstrated they can do it at the
moment on the historic records that's
the st. yeah coming home from what I
said earlier I have to disagree with my
friend castor kettle I don't think that
the applicant and her daughter should be
expected to share a bedroom for example
I didn't you sure I did oh I thought I
was listening carefully and you said
they did however so anyhow I think what
you've got there in the three bedroom
accommodation is a bedroom for the
applica one third daughter and a guest
bedroom which is not unreasonable
my concern is I'm going to take counsel
of Barnes's point about the tech room
being in a fairly secure place because
most tech is best quality Walsall
weather and therefore that's not going
to be inexpensive to buy or indeed even
to insure
indeed that there would be an adequate
way of covering that I do have concerns
about the feed store though because I
think that should be in the in the
stable block and not in the house thank
you and yeah I agree with lots of things
have been said is ten associated use
with the business which would
potentially cover the stack and the feed
is it can be the same deemed acceptable
as part of the application again I've
got no problems with the size the number
of bedrooms and there is a need or for
an agricultural tide that I think we
need to firm up my only slight concern
is to do with the financial viability
we've had we've had some reckon fight
some advise we employ consultants okay
we don't always accept what consultants
saying it's is that much of our judgment
but that's my only start concern because
of our sustainability and the viability
it's a two part test it's not only that
the need for it is also a viable ways
and there's some element today to my
mind whether about the viability based
on the information from Kernan's but
that's all I've got to say it was
something it was something up so I think
we need to move on and have we got any
proposal if you want to move it forward
I'm quite happy to blue will have nobody
supported be a second death for cancer
farms to approve
you're seconding as cattle or don't
speak so we've got a proposer and a
second yeah basically again we need to
go through the policies and conditions
that will need to apply to that as well
you're about to provide the conditions
they've done so are you saying catch the
barns that you think it's a sustainable
business and location and it meets the
relevant Paris and it's using its to do
with The Associated use of the business
is part of is ten-time I do you not with
the rest of the site would make it more
appropriate it's a careful you you
seconded though you've got any
conditions I'm happy to accept the
conditions I would repeat exact I think
we have to establish that this can only
be used as a rural rural workers
dwelling by over my own the owner of the
business the applicant and that the
apartment or whatever else you want to
call it on the ground floor I think
David said earlier on one could put a
restriction on that that it has to be
again used for for work a worker working
on on the side yeah I think our
preference in respect of that would not
be to grant a personal permission for
example where it would be named only for
the owner of the site it would be to tie
the occupancy of those dwelling zone and
I think on that basis as long as we have
those tight controls there is an issue
about lighting and I think we need to
ensure this is right next to the Aon B
it's right next to the
natural burial ground it is a sensitive
area I think we should have very tight
controls on lighting clearly needs to be
some security lighting but there is a
akeno's to have floodlights quite often
in in agricultural businesses I think
they should be seriously restricted to
ensure that if there is a PIR type light
in case there is an intruder that would
be acceptable but general flood lighting
after a certain time would be
unacceptable sounds reasonable to me
with the final wording to be agreed
between the perhaps Joe if you'd like to
go through a precis of standard
conditions so no I'll be honest we need
to do you need to make sure the
conditions before so you have time limit
standard three years of plans
landscaping we would remove the PD roads
because is no cultural toys and it's
been assessed on the essential need
actual solid toy condition the wording
would be put forward to make sure the
building was talking to the farmstead
sample materials to be submitted to the
council for approval standard ones on
these bins even charging points I was
recommended by environmental health land
determination and REM Edition if needed
and the removal of the outbuildings
everything else is been displayed on the
thing and lightning restrictions another
be it unless is one more because happy
well right we've had a proposer and a
second dirt that we grant the
application with conditions just we have
agreed and the reasons that we feel it
meets the n-double PF power 79 it meets
the financial test
and the sustainable location I don't
think it meets it doesn't I think it's
very difficult said it fails the
financial test it has been running for I
think since 2008 or something like that
we haven't got the information this
information is on board I think the
other the need to have an auroral workup
on the site because this is an
agricultural sorry isn't that quite
business but the problem is we have to
make sure we are it's part of the
sustainability it's not only toy it's
also the financial grounds if it were
unhappy it doesn't meet the financial
grounds we're therefore saying it's not
meeting that at the present time it is
moving towards that sentence or we
haven't got the latest figures but as
far as I can tell the business is
growing and like I said before 10 years
ago somebody had 50 sheep and now
they've got a thousand if they haven't
got asked to live in they can't they
can't promote their business so as far
as I'm concerned any conditions for
agriculture or to do with the business
needs to be solidly on so if the
business goes bust then they don't have
the house that's the obvious thing but
in the respective viability
it is nearly there but it will be soon
just don't say yeah just in respective
the NP PF the aim of the MPP F is to
promote sustainable satisfied that this
is a sustainable proposal a s-10 in
particular under the development
management considerations says that the
future sustainability of the enterprise
will be taken into consideration along
with the established function and
financial tests so if members are to
approve this they have to satisfy
themselves that they've considered the
sustainability and future sustainability
of the enterprise and that it has passed
a financial test in that respect
I think where I'd come from this is a
planning balance of what we're told
repeatedly of weighing up the benefits
now we have local support we have the
identified need in the Colonel's report
and the previous cannot report that
there is a need for overall work on this
dwelling
so there's ticks all those boxes and I
think the issue that we have about
furniture I don't think we are
comfortable at the moment they
historically it has ticked all the boxes
but as Council advances said that there
is there are facilities and I asked
about how big the plot was it could
expand considerably for marketers at the
moment it has the potential to go ahead
that is a little bit of a gray area but
I think in terms of the need for a world
while working or striving to be on site
is fundamental and I think that is very
strongly in his favor I would say that
sustainability primarily surveillance
Ostrander is only one part of
sustainability and he's an input it is
an important part I think in the terms
of the balance I don't think we can we
can't say absolutely historically it is
financially viable because we have been
told a question I think you need to be
satisfied that there is a need for the
need for permanent except except that I
just think it's a bit harsh to say we
are happy with the financial viability
historically with it because I think we
have a report that says historic it
hasn't but the future is it has all the
potential in the future I think that's
where our recommendation comes from
because the advice that we have from
Kernan's is that there's a business on
site there are accounts for that
business
it's a sole trader at the moment and the
counts are not at the level at which
Germans are happy to say that this is a
going to create a permanent need for a
permanent dwelling on that site there's
clearly a concern that this business may
not have some kids roots in quite as
deep as that yet and therefore that test
has not been passed I do agree with what
you're saying but I think the potential
we breathe in stock like he has in most
of the places has gone forward amassed
he's then used fully and I'm quite happy
too right so we are votes just make sure
we're clear what we were voting on that
one there's the need is and it's been
demonstrated for a rural worker or
however cancer careful products is it
and we feel that the business would be
able to sustain that need by its future
expansion because as new sedated by
councillor Barnes and we've got the
conditions that Jose mentioned so we've
had a proposal in a second should we go
for that now all those in favor three
for chairman Juancho committee resolves
to grant application 18 / 0 0 0 want a
few power right we'll move on swiftly to
our next application Odin can we join us
please
is 1803 3-1 Oh f-you our home farm
Loxley white erection of drumming
revised design to that approved under 18
/ 0 0 9 1 7 / issue ful and again our
case officer presents officer it's Jo
Thank You chair the application site is
located within the raw area of Locksley
directly to Norfolk north of an existing
access tract which runs from Goldie
clock roads to home farm the site area
equates to approximately fifteen hundred
and sixty squared meters or north when
16 hectares and sits between the
converted rounds at home farm located to
the southeast
and the proxy known as Four Winds
located northwest the land is currently
agriculture and nature parkland and
formed part of the wider land holding of
home phone on the site there is an
existing post and rail fencing on the
western southern eastern of seven
boundaries of boundaries furthermore the
southern boundary also consists of a
mature hedgerow there are no boundary
treatments to north-northeast of the
solid which is an open rule of character
it is ignores that the land Maxie Stokes
and the west to east direction falling
away from gory cut road the site is
located within the fold and special
landscape area this application seeks
permission for the erection of want
attacks joining to be located within the
vacant parcel and forming part of the
wider land holding of home farm Loxy as
witnessed by the floor plans the
application is seeking a four-bedroom
drilling with a study family area
kitchen and two on Suites the overall
footprint would acquire approximately
two hundred and ninety two point two
square meters the height of the dry line
will be set of eight point four meters
ridge and the dwelling will be
constructed out a red brick with brick
corns and chimney natural dark oedema
windows and doors
this is 3d drawings of the planet if it
was approved nice the front face in
principle elevation the slide in front
you display the extent permission exists
on the site under application reference
18 star zero zero nine one seven
this was improved on the fourth
apologies for the six 2018 this slide
shows you approved architectural
elevations of the expand permission of
the site the focus before you show the
access point to the site the one on the
Left go bang noises you go down to the
site and the dwelling will be situated
approximately here and the one on the
right shows it leading up to Gold cut
road this is the white rendered well to
avoid finished dwelling so that which
would be adjacent to it to its north
side this is the access road this
picture is directly opposite the road
this picture is leading away from
Locksley and this is directly opposite
as well the open field this is the
actual application site you can see
before you the white building just to
the north as dwelling would be situated
in his vacant parcel and as you can see
there is existing hedgerows and trees on
the outer boundaries this indicates the
whole site premises we have sort of 360
degrees so you've got the white down
there for your own reference to the
left-hand side that of these two red
brick sort of dwellings there behind
that bang to the south the red
bitterness is another open vacant parcel
land and then so really application site
is those single-story dwelling there but
it does have a two-story elements the
rear of that as well and that's the end
of the presentation
officer recommendation is for approval
and then no updates
Thank You Jo co-op our first speaker
please catch the Quinn Jones from
Locksley Parish Council thank you for
getting here and glad you didn't get
stuck in traffic unlike some of the
other attendees and sorry for keeping
you for so long you've got three minutes
and we'll give you a warning show with
about 30 seconds to it okay great
in brief we can't go through the full
planning history of this site but just
to note the history of it is contested
and it was originally approved on appeal
as a parish council we're just sensitive
about this site because it is in the
special landscape area as noted blood
flying officers our objections not to
the principle of development on this
site both the Parish Council and
actually nearby residents are happy with
the principle of development what we're
objecting to is the scale of this
development relative to neighboring
properties in what is a sensitive
planning context for those of you that
like numbers where there are
agricultural accountants or just normal
accountants to put that in context when
this was approved on appeal okay
it's now 28 percent longer as a
development and it's 21 percent higher
than the application approved on appeal
so I would say that's quite a
significant increase and we are
concerned in the context of the village
design statement that it's not
sympathetic to immediate immediate
surroundings and just to sort of put
that point of of tension between the
officer report and where we are it notes
that the overall footprint is 292 point
2 square meters of internal floor space
which is a reasonably large house that's
actually three times the size of the
average owner occupier hacks and so
that's a large house not a reasonably
large
house and it's reflective in the officer
report of a number of dwellings situated
in vicinity actually it's it's it's
large ring in floor space terms than
most of those in the local vicinity and
disappointed me I have a lot of floor
space figures to hand but certainly
that's if you look at some of the plans
that's that certainly comes across as
the case so we are objecting to it not
on the principle we'd be more than happy
with with something that reflected the
original permission on appeal but this
is quite a significant extension in
terms of Heights and width of the
building given the sensitive planning
context and therefore as a Parish
Council we are objecting to this
particular development but not the
principle of development on this seed
site indeed this is in our draft
neighborhood development plan just to
put that in context twenty seconds to
spare before we start about as a member
of the accounting profession I would
state there's no such thing as a normal
good evening counselor obviously we
haven't got the ward member present this
evening I just wondered whether any
discussions had taken place with Council
O'Donnell and whether she was in whether
she was in support of your own views it
furnished no discussions have taken
place I don't know whether she is in or
not in support of it but but clearly our
views have been stated within the in
response to the planning application no
sorry no it's not all one property it's
not it's a number it's about there are
about
at least four it could be five but
there's at least four for you an engine
yeah it's not a conservation or listed
no it's not listed its historic but it's
not listed
it's a typical Warwickshire historic
farmhouse and then you've got barns and
outbuildings that have been converted
basically yeah thank you the applicant
the agent to come to your parish meeting
to discuss this any consolation
basically no no I mean we would we were
disappointed and I must admit I was
slightly caught out because I expected
that on in when the inspector came to
review the proposal we would have been
consulted as a parish council I didn't
realize that we automatically wouldn't
necessarily be and but as I say this
does represent a significant increase on
that approval on appeal and it also just
doesn't sit with the village design
stone which the district council also
support okay thank you can see Catalan
you indicate are you okay no okay okay
thank you very much thank you for thanks
mentioning normal accountants just
finished the second round of regulation
14 consultations yes
the site is included within the plan as
I say as a parish council we're more
than happy in principle with development
on this site and actually just saying
about that let's go yeah yeah yes I did
hear you say that we thank you very much
right our next speakers please which is
Jane cashflow and Robert Lindsay
how you supposed to miss Joe no you
speaking I'm going to take the time and
then he stays here for any questions
that's a lie Thank You Farley good
evening thank you for the opportunity of
speaking as your officer has explained
permission already exists on the site
for the erection of a dwelling so the
principle of a dwelling is established
in my seeking permission for a different
design to that's already approved there
now propose dwelling lies in exactly the
same red line area it uses the same
access and it's also for a four-bed
Welling
the Office report comprehensively covers
the key issues so I'll just address the
parish council objections firstly sighs
the proposed dwelling is larger in floor
space than that already approved but
that does not automatically mean it's
unacceptable what is now proposed is not
out of keeping with surrounding houses
the proposed house has a narrow plumb
depth with longer frontage which
reflects the shape of the plot the house
has been designed fairly close to the
rear boundary because it has open views
over agricultural land with its main
garden area to be sited to the side
which will also protect the existing
willow tree the house which already has
permission is also cited a similar
distance to the same rear boundary the
site is not over developed the side
garden area alone measures over 320
square meters this is larger than the
rear garden areas of October house and
Meadow View and weigh in excess of
minimum garden sizes set out in the
guidance in meeting housing needs in
terms of parking three parking spaces
are shown for a four-bed house and this
meets your emerging parking standards if
you consider more parking is required
this could be resolved by a hard
landscaping scheme which increases hard
standing to the front of the property
but the three spaces shown does accord
with your emerging standards in terms of
design on the screen are some photos of
properties in the vicinity of the
application site the Parish Council
considers considers the design to be out
of character but this is not agreed in
allowing the appeal for the extant
dwelling on site the inspector
I could not discern any defining design
characteristic the area is predominantly
residential and comprises two-story
dwellings in a variety of styles and
materials the proposed design is
two-story measures eight point four
meters too rich is constructed of red
brick has timber windows and two small
front facing gables as you'll see from
the photos these design features and
materials can also be seen on houses in
the immediate vicinity of the
application site there should be 2
slides in terms of levels the house is
sited down a private road and the levels
are lower than gold ticket road
therefore views of the house would be
barely possible from the public highway
and this is confirmed in 32nd lot the
officer report sets out that the
proposed siting design and scale of the
dwelling reflects the character of the
area is well cited within the village
context and that the proposal does not
harm the landscape quality of the area I
hope you agree and are able to support
your officers recommendation to grant
thank you thank you any questions no r1
briefly obviously we've been on facts
and figures today and again just I know
you've touched on it in your
presentation 28% increase in width and
21% increase in height I know you said
you didn't doesn't necessarily just
qualify that just to confirm you're used
to doing I don't have that exact
percentages for you but the the height
quoted in the parish councils response
of the existing approval allowed on
appeal the parish council say at 7
meters in the officer report it's at 7.2
so I don't think the percentage quoted
is is accurate in that respect
and I'm not sure on the the width of the
property
I haven't measured that or done that
calculation
we haven't got a ward member here
tonight for this one no so go on two
points of clarification any points of
clarification okay Joe do we have a
comparison of the original footprint for
the approved application which we can
compare sorry if I missed it if you put
it on the screen with the proposed I
don't have percentages but I can give
you what was approved in the external
permission so here is their original
property that is stamped on their will
measure seventeen point five meters wide
eleven point five meters deep at a high
at 7.2 meters this property I stated
will be eight point four meters too rich
and we're a square foot print of two
hundred and ninety two point two square
meters width wise don't you have them
figures in front of me that's the only
issue with it I don't have to work with
new application so you said the
footprint was children ninety-two and
the width was I don't have the width
were always in front of me that's the
only measurement and suddenly order
because the once it was underlying
meters high that's correct the dwelling
proposed eight point four meters
I thought you've got to do it in your
head to catch the kettle is the farming
management accountant stable so on that
it would be the original footprint was
201 square meters and this is 292 what
would you become for that as a
comparison as a comparison yeah I mean
I'm more than happy to go into the
reasons why if you wish me to go in some
reasons the difference between the
reason we've associated that building
even though this one is bigger to what
is being proposed here it's that's what
sixth and yes I think in this respect
it's important that members don't
misdirect themselves the officers report
has assessed the application proposed on
its own merits there is an existing
permission however as I say that the
design appearance and layout of this
application has been assessed by the
officer in respect of the vernacular of
the area and the site itself the
conclusions before members that the
design in our view is acceptable in
terms of its scale and height in
appearance you can see it on there which
is by the neighboring provinces and you
see their footprints normally it would
be slightly larger you have home from
parish councils correct
I've been divided that's reasonably
large you've also got the dryness and
north and a lot also how large dwellings
agreed this application would be
slightly bigger but we've also took into
context its location each site it down a
rural road within the physical confines
of the village and so forth
well the hoist a point for the issue
being with that and let me just trying
to throw up is you might just see
there's a slope which rises right up to
goal to cut roads so if you have a look
at though on the Left this 20 M will be
set here and then although it's eight
point four meters deuter's slope in our
opinions it wouldn't be a domineering
effect
I think the agent mentioned okay so the
previous plan you showed that that white
house that's the same white house in
both those photographs taken tonight
besides where is that white house on the
on the footprint plan this would be the
White House just situated here with the
adjacent property for wind we move on to
the bite on this one that catch the
barns and cast on appeal and then one
and they came back in that the same
thing but as far as I'm concerned then
it's a big ads on a big plot which is
what is in the area under somewhat the
PI's cancel the same but I understand
what the officers are saying Thank You
chair um in line with councilor bonds I
don't have any issues with this I think
it it is a large house but it is on a
large plot we already have a commission
for a fairly good-sized property there
and have it I'm happy to second
counselor Barnes is proposal
okay sir I think it is it is a big house
I think it does take up a significant
amount of that plot particularly in a
rural village but it is surrounded by
fields currently and therefore possibly
will settle better into the landscape
that you might otherwise think I've
referred seen something smaller but I
take what the officer has said and done
I'm not mr. Jeffrey said these assess it
fully in light of that setting so I will
I'm happy to support bonds Perry's
support the officer I was in favor of
granting the application for chairman
against German and abstentions one
chairman sir committee resolves to grant
application 18 / 0 3 3 1 0 fel move on
to our final application the evening
she's 18 slashed the road to 83 plus fu
o land adjacent to 43 mana Road hobbling
I wish to go home and change you go
around machine could you have we got a
quorum to carry on on condition he does
my sheep as well first can we can we
decide who's staying and who's going
catch the party said she was willing to
stay if you need to go by Jewish have
condition you might as well
carry on as sheep you can go right on
come on please I know it's been a long
night
that's just have just a slight
adjournment while Spencer Perry is able
to yet no that's why well beside the
German wants to do that and then we'll
start this application
we were on to the final item which is 18
/ 0 - 8 8 3 ful and adjacent to 43
Monroe armory erection of one and a half
story chalet-style darling with new sari
accessing car parking and Joe is
presenting this again Thank You chef the
application site is located within the
garden number 43 mile road within the
built-up area boundary of Harbury as you
can see on the black dot before you
number 43 is a semi detached 2-story red
brick dwelling with pit Roos and is
represented the dwelling toys fronting
onto Manor Road and bushy flame a measly
Jason to the side to the west is a
recent development a certified and
approved in 2014 and 2015 respectively
a measly to the south of a button the
proposed Red Line boundary is a sewage
pumping station beyond the station of
the 2009 development which contains a
mixture of the taximeter types and
Terrace properties including four
bungalows constructed with a palette of
natural stone and red brick access to
the site is proposed from Bush he flame
the application is not situated in any
landscape and all historic designations
this application c4 mission for the
erection a wand attached to an end to be
located in the rear guard and the white
of the hot land over Denver number 43
Munger Road the dwelling is proposed to
be sited in the center of the rear
garden or number 43 were a small real
garden its own acquaintance to
approximately 70 square meters
if approved the proposal would see the
erection of a new one on our storied
wailing some point for me is to ridge
with an overall development footprint of
140 square meters the dwelling would be
constructed on a white render white PVC
windows with a rich Salvage of course
grade concrete slated roof and a brick
Coughlin and dental course with timber
doors the image before you shows the
indicative plans of what the joining
would look at planning permission was
forthcoming
once again this shows of 3d versions of
the dwelling from its principal
elevation and its rear elevation
respectively the photos before we use
the application site the APIs of the
dwelling would be saudis just here to
left hand side is number 43 which
presently is the garden area this shows
number 43 here the joinin will be
approximately round there and shows the
it solid extension where number 43 would
get its we'd have a rare garden on the
side garden first residential means is
this is a front through onto number 43
that's number 43 there adjoining will be
situated approximately around there once
again on the right hand side you see the
drawing situate there there is a large
amount of headroom which faces onto
bushy flowing where access is attained
just where the car is seen these are the
dwelling types are in the area this is
number 43 which is semi touch to the
neighbor and property this is the velum
easily Jason the site to the west this
is a measly Jason to the side to the
north hidden into Harbor you can see the
stars and developments once again a
measly Jason you can see on the new
development in 2014 and 16 that why
Brenda has been introduced and the style
of buildings within that area this is an
aerial shot now it's a little like a
date here because most this development
now has been constructed you
see there isn't meant to be a red line
of is not showing it very well so
apologies that but this is number 43 and
the plan is there this here is the
pumping station and as you can see on
the two photos to the side the site will
be situated here where it's residence
many boundaries there and parking and so
forth and this is the gated access to
the pumping station these photos
demonstrates across soap rocks me
they're taken over where the pumping
station is fenced off there is a small
pathway down there and you can see
number 43 on the line above and that's
the end of the presentation our
recommendation is for refusal there are
updates on the update see a request for
further information on the pump station
was sent to SDC Environmental Health the
response was I don't have any details of
the sewage pumping station in particular
you would have to ask seven Trump
details what I can tell you the sewage
pumping stations can lead to a complaint
of odor and there could also be a noise
impact from the pumps including low
frequency noise which is difficult to
measure and control I don't have any
complaints regarding this particular
permanent station but the new property
would be in very close proximity in
hence the potential for problems much
higher request was sent to seven drone
on the 30th of the 1st 2019 and the 4th
of the second 29 in relation to the
pumping station however we haven't
received any responses apart from their
initial consultation and from the SDC
Environmental House response Harvey
Parish Council have woodrue their
original support as they even their
response following consultation we were
Joris 4 and from that counts there
Harris also we drew hers restore in
response to SDC environmental health
thank you thank you Joe move on to our
first speaker
Noemi Cox
Naomi will be speaking father's there
just to support her we're not really
scary
I wanted to once in my vapor arm though
you've got three minutes if you'd like
to press the middle button and we'll
give you a shout with 30 seconds to say
you've got 30 seconds episode take your
time deep breath and don't be scared of
us thank you yeah it's just checking
okay I'm just gonna read so the main
objection
well the objection is for my mental
health any building on this site would
be subject to smiles noise and vibration
from the nearby pumping station the plot
is part of my father's garden and he
parks his car daily right next to the
station which he could see on the
photographs in the almost 10 years that
that station has been there my father
has never experienced any smells or
noise coming from the station the garden
of the new property is currently my
furthest back garden and the proximity
of the station has an aberrant at him
from enjoying this amenity in the way is
being suggested there is an eight-foot
fence and a row trees there praising the
plot from the station and my agent has
suggested we could use further planting
and specialist fencing designed to
reduce noise the proposed building will
be triple-glazed further reducing the
like bit of disturbance as to concerns
about vibrations my agent has suggested
it's possible to have materials to the
foundation with capacity to absorb the
vibration that may move through the
ground and he also commented that if
it's possible to build earthquake proof
of housing surely we can mitigate the
effects of the pumping station I would
like to add that we're a family with
young child who's struggling to find
suitable affording house affordable
housing in the area in which we grew up
building a low cost and frame house and
my father's land is our chance to do
this
we've been living with family for just
over two years or
and on the council housing list this is
actually our second application our
first was refused for reasons which we
accept and at the time we were told that
this was not a refusal in principle so
we spent the next year rethinking the
project and saving the money to put in a
new application but what we've been
presented with is a refusal in principle
[Music]
so um the case officer Tom made and he
wasn't aware of the pumping station on
our last application and the
environmental health didn't pick up
either I told my agent that they had
been aware of the station their advice
to us would have been different
so really this oversight if it's the
thing that stops this building has that
the very least put is financial
disadvantage this year been picked up
before with recent money on a new
application which you're now saying
could never have been successful and we
could have spent the money China has
ourselves in the different way
sober feeling that time Thanks thank you
yes the saint yes chairman sorry no how
amazing yeah you referred a moment ago
in your presentation to advise that
there wouldn't be a refusal in principle
on this site and you've now seen the
paperwork that we've been given which
suggests that that's exactly what should
happen so can you be specific about
receiving that contrary advice
requested a site visit on the last
application because we were told that it
would be recommended for a feasel for
design reasons so so we say Joe Brooks
came along to the site and we had a good
discussion and we understood where he
was coming from with the design issues
and and I do remember saying so so it's
not in principle that we could couldn't
build here okay it's sufficient to tell
me that he came to see you first of all
thank you very much for your
presentation this is probably just a
question to your your father in terms of
have you have you lived on this
particular site and in terms of was was
the pumping station there before you
lived although it was there and then
you've moved to the site no I've lived
on the site for in excess of 30 years
and the pumping stations been there for
about ten and I must admit when I found
out it was going to be sited there I
obviously objected and I was very
pessimistic and I thought well it's
going there's going to be smells going
to be no ease it's got to be awful but
it just hasn't happened there's been
nothing at all
I have never detected to smell certainly
not a noise vibration it hasn't it
hasn't interfered at all in the use of
my garden whatsoever closest proximity
to theirs to the pumping station and the
environmental health actually saying
that they've had no complaints and you
know I don't know of any complaints and
I certainly haven't had any adverse
experience rot I just need to make this
point for the recording there's not a
problem mister
can anyone just that you weren't ready
to speak but in light of the situation
and how long meetings gone on the
utility needs is a support its Tomatoes
just discretion that you're I have to
come off and answer the questions on
given that discretion now just so it
doesn't so if people are watching this
or watch it a later date and you weren't
register to speak I've given you
permission to do so it's part of our
discussion and then a long wait about
I've got a question for you as well I
assume this is apparent that you were if
you thought there was an issue with
regarding smells either vibration you
wouldn't wish your daughter to be closer
to that body well absolutely not my
daughter and my new 18-month or
granddaughter absolutely not state their
ten years has there been an ongoing
problem smell whatever yeah just wanted
to point out right point I want to make
so carefully keep on doing this to me in
the I don't know if had not to look at
the bosses appalled but he refers to
policy eight zero one of the
neighborhood development plan which was
approved by Harbor Parish Council in
fact adopted by this council in December
and therefore it does carry full
planning weight which says do not need
the inappropriate lengths of residential
gardens that would cause harm to the
village by reason of those of
development significant loss of usable
garden space for both existing and
proposed new properties what proportion
of your existing garden will you be
taking up the new property he's in the
report so I did I was trying to find it
but I couldn't
first of all I'm sorry it's less than
half I don't have a percentage but if
you have a look on the diagram and the
officer himself in his report said he
was satisfied it wasn't moving too much
and obviously if Harvey about their plan
adopted and they were concerned about
the spice being used or building
inappropriately would they have not
mentioned that in the objection just
it's just a question to question
something so I think we've had stop
question any feel free to go back to the
more concrete chairs and behind you
thank you
what's up come and catch the party from
that image there whereabouts is the
pumping station from the photograph it
looks like it's set back quite a long
way from the road it's a the case that
is the pumping station so it's the other
side of the track from the house itself
where the professor's gonna be well yes
so you've got the red line boundaries so
this is part of the pump stations
curtilage that is the pumping station so
that's the red line boundary to it so
that is the separation distance from
there to there
Thank You Chet just clarification on on
the cell I've obviously I presume I've
got this wrong I was just under the
impression that for a self-build
property sell its exempt from sale
you are correct but the way we do our
recommendation officers report they have
to demonstrate it after approval of
driving permission that it is a self
build so it is still liable it would be
liable for that amount but once they
have attained planning permission they
claim an exemption so if the property
was not adjacent to the pumping station
would you ask the officer take the same
view I think I think I have to go back
to some context on the so an application
was returned and they didn't mention of
as a site meeting undertook that site me
and there was concerns regarding
residence the meaning in design they
have overcome them concerned they've
also to be fair to the applicants went
to the ward member in Paris and dressed
their concerns on the original
application has always suggested what
didn't happen on that reasonable
application which was drawn was
environmental health said that they had
no representation to the pumping station
for this reason is what to go down along
the recommended refusal for this
application
it wasn't highlighted to me by by
environment off on the first application
I think just to add a further comment is
clearly all that has been the case the
first application all the issues were
brought to light what I would say
however is as you'll be aware the
statutory Undertaker who operates that
pumping station is at liberty through
their own permitted development rights
to operate as they see fit so although
there may not be noise from it they may
not be smelled from it at the current
time this planning authority doesn't
have direct and complete control over
that
and so the use of that land in the
future and the way in which it operates
may change I think that that's the
principal cause for the environmental
health officers comment that in a
general sense pumping stations for
sewage can cause complaints can cause
odor can cause noise and vibration and
given the extremely close proximity of
this proposed dwelling that's the cause
for his objection the reason for refusal
sets out that it's it's 9 to 10 meters
away from the actual facility if they
were to exercise their permitted
development rights which clearly they
have would they would there not be some
environmental control over any
enhancement of odor possibly
enhancements the wrong word increase in
odor you know what I mean
increase in odor levels so you know if
they were to change it from a closed
system which doesn't produce any smells
to an opener
whatever would that be acceptable
permitted development or would we turn
around our mental health team and say I
think it would be the controlling use of
that land the maintenance of their
machinery and equipment is permitted
development there may well be all the
legislation through environmental health
or licensing anything like that that
might impact their effective use of that
land but through the determination of
this planning application all we can do
is really consider whether these are
appropriate and neighboring land uses
another question sorry the area around
here you've got the new development
below it in your picture Joe is is all
brick the original estate in Manor Road
is all brick number 43 is brick this
they even go forward to plan for it
please he's in complete contrast to the
brick if you had not got the
environmental health issue would the
design of this being very different to
the existing design and of course you
any concerns this is a good point
I'm mentally on when we first met on
sight
why Grendel at once again was supposed
on the area and I did suggest probably
looking into brick but to be fair to the
applicants if you have a look around the
area and and literally adjacent you
can't see why grander buildings are in
that area there it's not with anything
special landscape areas there's good
landscaping there already a condition if
planning permission was forthcoming
would be put involved I don't think it
would be a reason to not recommend
approval for the application just based
on like Brenda can it be condition that
actually the it's brick rather than
render or it's not rendered so that does
fit in I accept what you're saying about
there are the buildings but this part of
Harbury is predominantly brick all the
way through and this would be
significantly different
speaking to my colleague we would
probably have to do a notwithstanding
condition to make sure they would agree
to avoid it could be appealed if we
could propose and notwithstanding for
the materials to be submitted and
therefore brick
so it would be fancy signed off by the
LPA severely judging from what the
applicants said they were are going to
take into account vibration and also
odors with the design of the windows and
the foundations I would have thought
that would limit the amount of problems
they had and quite honestly sorry
probably I'm going into into debate
rather than I would have thought it's
their own problem if they if they want
to bill there and and being fully aware
of the problems that surround them I
think if the precis if the question is
whether noise fencing vibration proof
foundations and triple glazed windows
would be adequate to overcome the
concerns of the environment health
officer
the answer is we haven't been formally
proposed those as elements of this
scheme they haven't been formally
submitted and therefore they haven't
been formally assessed an informal
conversation took place it was
understood that they didn't overcome the
environmental health officers concerns
but at this stage because they're not
part of the proposal in a formal sense
we can't confirm that they would
adequately overcome those environmental
health issues again can we make it a
condition that the concern for officers
is that although we could condition
those details to be submitted and agreed
by the planning authority we're not at
this stage confident and they overcome
the concerns raised raised by the
environment Health Officer will you be
alright to ask them to deal with that
and come back
with a with the amendment it wouldn't be
reasonable for us to impose a condition
that could effectively take away their
planning permission if you see what I
mean so if we would be for example
asking for a report that assess odor and
considered the potential mitigation if
the result of that report was that there
wasn't potential mitigation the effect
of that condition would be to negate
their planning permission that would not
be reasonable or enforceable so my
concern would be very much that that
information needs to be part of a
planning application if mitigation is
proposed rather than something that
comes through condition but if it was
refused they could come back with an
amended scheme we can we move this on
there I think we're with five to ten
that unless we've got some things that's
from Garrity just a very quick one the
applicant has said that they would do
slightly relations that I'm sorry he did
say or she did say that they would be
putting in built should take out
vibration can we condition that as that
as a commitment they've actually made
seedling in honesty I don't know I don't
know if those details are feasible for
this site I don't know what those
details would be I don't know if they'd
be appropriate or effective I would
struggle to advise members as to whether
or not that would overcome the concerns
of the environmental health officer or
be an achievable
point yes chairman there seems to be
some uncertainty over guidance given to
the applicant and I quitter about this
and she said that mr.
we paid a visit and that have given rise
to a belief in her part that effectively
there wouldn't be a recommendation for a
few Soria we were confronted with just
that with the officers like to comment
on that Chris Koster although I have of
the applicant about twenty years ago as
I previously said and I didn't ever
guarantee planning permission I can
confirm that completely system by
case-by-case basis but I said we did an
assault visit I did 21-day consultation
of the previous application
environmental health
I knew the pumping station but
environmental health never commented on
the pumping station so my professional
opinion was they didn't have any
concerns there
I raised my issues with the application
they have addressed them issues on the
new application even though I didn't
guarantee planning permission I never
would as an officer I'll be stupid you
they suck the environmental health have
come up saying that this is an issue
well we we have another case chairman
haven't we well we've got the Parish
Council and the ward member supporting
this application and then withdrawing
that simple because of this
environmental evidence
notice that my round is new I think
we've got clarified that you move on to
the debate there kiss the power thank
you I start I mean this is this is a
unique situation where you've got the
applicant wanting to take on a self
build opportunity within within the land
albeit adjacent to the pumping station
from that perspective you know they're
not it's not an open market property or
it's not in that although I appreciate
at some stage later on it could become
an open market property but at the end
of the day the applicant is prepared to
no no it's self-build
so it's for its for the other members of
the family yeah but I self-build
relation to SIL it's not the same
sessemann undertook into the core
strategy fine but what I'm saying is the
risk is down to two the owner off of the
actual property and at the end of the
day environmental health didn't come up
with this didn't identify the problem on
the first application I'm inclined to
support this application because if the
outlook if the applicants are happy that
there isn't the problem with odors
they're the people living on the site
there isn't the problem with the
vibrations and and in the interest of
its within the built up area boundary
and I would be happy to support this
application self-build exemption I
believe you have to live in the property
for three years to actually claim the
exemption sorry can I just come back can
I just come back to but on the other
ripping the applicant has mentioned that
this is also for his daughter and
granddaughter so it is the applicant
wouldn't be would be living no
restrictions applying to this yes to
clarify there's no description in the
development that says it's a self built
there's no tie or personal permission
proposed
there's no undertaking that this will be
restricted only to people from the local
village or local market needs this is an
open market dwelling fun careful
fielding I'm happy to go along with
calipari as far as that's concerned it's
up to them and they will be building
their own house be it nearest if it
affects the value if they ever get
around to selling it that's their own
problem I'm quite happy to go ahead with
it up to the point of the environmental
health officers comment we both the
parish and the ward member accepted it
and I think that it's very much up to
them and the Environmental Health
Officer hasn't actually specifically
stated that there is a problem he said
there may be a problem I think I
followed by my colleagues whether or not
they live in it long term that's not
their option clearly as council fielding
I said if it is appalling ly excited
nobody's going to buy it from them
they're going to be left with the white
elephant so there is a personal risk
which they're gonna have to take you
putting this forward I take fully your
concerns about environmental health
although as Council fiddling have said
the may not will do it's like highways
issue where you've got like what was
they call site lines etc etc it is that
there is room in the garden might my one
concern I think it's it's not trivial
but I think I would very much like a
condition that the surface reflects the
step that the the brickwork that we've
seen all the rest of the way through
Harbury acknowledging there are
differences but the majority of that
estate were all built out of brick and I
would like to see that as a condition
that we have visibility to make sure
that fits in mr. Jeffers going to tell
me I can't
but press the button but I would be if
it's a proposal has put forward my
concern here is that we have
environmental health advice that is
telling us that this proposal is likely
to result in amenity conditions that are
adverse for future residents although
members may say it's case of buyer
beware and future occupiers won't buy it
policy cs9 sets out the District
Council's approach to those sorts of
issues under point 8 it says you know
proposals will be healthy will ensure a
good standard of amenity for occupiers
and that will include buildings and
neighborhoods being protected from
unacceptable and an adverse surroundings
in the absence of information other than
we have before us I can't quite see
where members are reaching conclusions
that overcome the environmental health
officers concerns I think that's
probably can I just come back has the
environmental officer physically gone to
the site measured the noise vibrations
and the odors not as far as I'm aware
but almost they are obviously aware of
the proximity of so it's desktop
analysis desktop appraisal which
concludes this extremely close in in
those sorts of situations there are
often issues forum surely if there is a
problem it's down to seventh renter
rectified it depends on oh that they
decide that they potentially have got
permitted development and it depends on
what they do and it's it's not under
this site it depends on the type of
nuisance I've provided so we might be
able to tackle out nuisance in different
ways but we do have to take into account
that is but I've got permitted
development right which could
potentially change the situation that
we've got now so that's the tough thing
that's why you see the proposed rolling
the may be a risk of noise disruption
from maintenance and all odour so I
think we're on the cusp of may and going
back to what I said earlier on where
highways could be quite definitive sight
lines on thing met there is a certain
ambivalence here which I think it's very
difficult one but we do not be able to
build a house and then find it's
unlivable because that would just be a
waste of everybody's time and effort and
we do have a not a duty of care in the
legal sense but we do have a duty to the
future think it was touched in it
certainly is touched on in cs9 I think
it comes down to the purpose of the
planning system one of the key things
that the planning system has to achieve
is to ensure that neighboring land uses
are appropriate
and you know to set it all to buyer
beware is somewhat circumventing the
purposes of the planning system in in
that respect when we receive a planning
application assesses officers what we
try to achieve a situation where it is
for the developer to demonstrate that
the proposal is acceptable and in
accordance with the development plan in
this case officers are advising you that
in respect to cs9 we are not satisfied
that this is an acceptable proposal they
have not crossed that threshold and that
is based on the advice of the
environmental health officer right I
think I think we've divided this
sufficiently enough we've had a provider
and a second to grant the application so
all right okay
sorry Wow what can you free fresh you
can supply what did you just say I'll
support sorry you are not miss miss her
yeah yeah I think that at the moment we
haven't got a proposal we we've still
got a lot of uncertainty about whether
we there are things that can be put in
to mitigate or the current or potential
noise pollution odor issues vibration as
well we've not clear on what we're
proposing to do here okay so phone
I just want I'm on concerns that we've
got a very strong objection from
environmental health officer who has not
actually physically gone out to visit
the site and I therefore think because
of the seriousness of a strong objection
from environmental health I wonder
whether there's merit in actually
deferring and we get the environmental
team out there physically to look at it
and assess the situation on-site yeah
I'm happy to second that proposal I was
hoping we'll assume there's a proposal I
was so we are waiting for information
from some trend from in the update sheet
it's not sitting happy with me I must
admit I'm concerned that we need to get
this right I'm concerned about the
future potential of permitted
development of the site at the pumping
station and as part of CS law because
duty and obligation to make sure we
build places but in a healthy
environment so I'm happy to second cat
surprise proposal to defer the
application to get sufficient
information back from the Environmental
Health Officer back from seven trend and
we make sure we've dotted the i's cross
the t's so we can then make a reasoned
decision on this so on this summer's got
anything else different to add we've got
a proposal and second and I'm
- so we've got a proposal on a second to
defer the application to seek more
information from the seven trend from
environmental health and potentially for
the applicant to provide more
information for mitigation is that is
that reasonable so all those in favor
committed is result of where the
application for the reasons mentioned in
the debate and that's we is definitely
then thank you